maybe that's something the committee
should take into account too
thank you for your testimony the chair
can inquire with one question sure and
thank you for taking my question
in a situation where one person own is
unmarried
owns owns a house or property
is it why would that long-term living
partner have some type of vested
interest in the property i guess that's
the concern i would have
i i well just the
thank you for the question but
right off the top my head i would say
probably only if they invested in that
property also
so if they have a clear track or trail
of investment if they're paying half the
mortgage or something like that
but if it was fully owned by one partner
you know i think
i don't think they would have
necessarily access to it although i
think that kind of question would be a
see no hands raised thank you for your
testimony the witness is excused thank
you very much
how do i do this
ah thank you i'm new at this
thank you i'm chelsea christensen and
thank you for hearing my testimony
hopefully in
what i have to say my answer a lot of
the questions that i'm hearing you ask
i'll just give you a little background
on my story and why i approached senator
sherman on this bill
i was in a relationship with someone for
10 years
it was more on the traditional side of
things we were together had two children
bought a house together that kind of
thing
when it ended i learned through the
process of separation
that the laws are
very challenging for someone in my
situation
um
where this could apply to a lot of
different types of relationships you
know whether it's same-sex and you know
what have you there's a lot of different
scenarios
um me being more in a traditional sense
um where we you know cohabitated raise
children
my situation was i felt that
the way the laws are designed in new
hampshire for divorce it's a very 50 50
state when you're separating with
children it's 50 50 in just the means of
child support
um
the reason why divorce laws are said the
way they are is because traditionally
there's going to be a scenario where you
know someone stays home raises the
children the other person goes off and
earns for the household they save for
their retirement they do these things
they're benefiting from the other
partners staying home keeping things
going while they're off doing their job
and saving for retirement and what have
you
when you separate in that situation when
you're not married there's no protection
to
help the other person have a consistent
lifestyle when you leave as far as you
know there was some huge discrepancies
in the separation where yes i had child
support but he continued to live in the
household which we did split and to
answer some of the questions about how
do you split a house
there is currently
coverage in new hampshire for what's
called tenants in common and we did
invest in the house together so we were
able to prove that you know that needed
to be split 50 50. so he did buy me out
of my portion of the house so if that
answers any of those questions
but as far as
anything else i i was expected because i
don't know if you're familiar with the
law code air versus code air in the
state of new hampshire if one person is
determined that they pay full child
support then the recipient of the child
support is expected to pay for
everything for the child
as far as camps and after school
activities and things like that and they
can't go to the other person paying the
child support for additional like you
know let's split the ballet and all that
it's expected that that person pays for
everything
that is what i do i pay for everything
for my children which i'm happy to do
because i want them to have those
opportunities but then there's a
discrepancy where he's the breadwinner
he's saved for retirement so on and so
forth when we separated i just get child
support i pay for everything
you know he's living in a nice house i'm
in a one-bedroom apartment with two kids
and two dogs and it it became very
difficult and i realized that when you
separate in that situation
the laws aren't there to protect me to
say well you also get 50 50 because you
each benefited from a 10-year
relationship you know you should also
get the alimony and the um you know half
of the retirement things like that
that's what you get when you get
divorced but when you get
separated in a domestic partnership
there's no protection there
so there's a huge discrepancy in
you know offering the same lifestyle for
the children in one household versus the
other
and
you know during the study maybe it's
determined that
how they decide on
what the benefits are when you separate
in a domestic partnership maybe there's
qualification things maybe it's length
of time maybe it's do you have children
together do you have assets things like
that um but it's it's been very
challenging in this process um because
it's just
it you know it's expected that i pay for
everything and then i also have to
maintain a household and everything else
and i don't make as much money and i
don't work the way he does and i have to
take a lot of time to run the kids and
things like that so the amount of money
that we're getting to help support the
two households is a is very off
and um
i just looked at it and you know i
approached senator sherman because i
said you know there should be something
that protects all different types of
relationships there isn't just you know
i was in more of a traditional sense of
a relationship but there's other
domestic partnerships you know they
might adopt children they might be in
the same situation
another example that was hard for me
during the separation is
his work was always based in other
states so i was able to get domestic
partnership
healthcare which was great but of course
the minute we separated he just canceled
it so whereas i was getting the benefit
of health care
and i couldn't do anything about it now
i'm paying you know 450 for 450 a month
on my health care whereas i was getting
it for you know 100 a month and there's
just discrepancies like that that make
it very challenging in the state
um
i think that's pretty much all i had to
say i don't know if i should open it up
for questions
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
the witness for a testimony okay if
there's anything i just want to say i
don't know you kind of cut short in
anticipation of questions senator
sherman left so
i just didn't know if he wanted me to
add to that but
that's pretty much why i feel like this
thank you for your testimony okay
witness is excused oh excuse me oh sorry
go ahead sorry
my mistake representative news you're
recognized i did have one question about
what is what is the impact of some of
the things that you're going through as
a custodial parent that you think might
be a little bit different
than a custodial parent
in a situation where a divorce has taken
place well in in my situation it's more
just trying to make sure that my
children are maintaining the same
lifestyle that they're accustomed to in
two households
so not having enough money i feel that
the way the laws were designed in a
divorce they they look at that they look
at okay here you know for 10 years
you've been raising children together
and they've had a certain lifestyle when
you separate from a marriage let's make
sure that the children have an equal
opportunity in each household so there
is the alimony to help support you know
everything's based on income his income
is much higher than mine
so it's definitely something where
i feel like i'm struggling because i'm
trying to help my children have
maintained that same lifestyle and pay
for all their things and all that but
it's you know i haven't been able to i
mean up until recently i fortunately was
able to to get myself going with a new
home and that kind of thing it took a
while it took about three four years for
me to get to that point but you know i
was living in a one bedroom apartment
and so
i feel if i had had the additional
income maybe the retirement things that
i can fall back on you know i don't have
the ability to save for retirement i
have no retirement i mean hopefully
maybe my house will give me some equity
but you know me helping him save her
retirement i didn't benefit from any of
that and i feel like alimony and things
additional funds would help me have a
nicer home for them and keep things a
little bit more consistent from
household to household
that's why i just feel like this bill is
pretty important for people in my
situation
thank you mr chairman who made the
decision of
visitation rights for the children and
whatnot
so at least the good news about
separating when you when you're not
married is the state of new hampshire
does have
a pretty comprehensive
i guess if you want to call it parenting
plan or what have you when you separate
they look at the children and they look
at the income excuse me and they they do
separate things very well you go into
court together when you separate and you
you have to agree on a parenting plan
it's you know whether it's going to be
50 50 visitation or maybe one parent
works more and they travel more so the
other parent needs to take more
responsibility um but
when it comes to the children the laws
are there for that type of thing um
i don't know if that answers your
question
yes it does okay
you recognize for a follow-up
i was just curious because
you had to go before a judge in order to
get this right
yes
okay yeah we had to have court hearings
and that kind of thing to agree we had
to have mediation and
it felt like a divorce at that point
when it came to
um you know making sure the children
were well cared for so i will say that
about new hampshire is that that that is
a positive thing it's just when it comes
to
you know separating everything it
there's no protections for a domestic
partnership
okay thank you
representative welch
thank you
i i guess mike my question is kind of a
personal one
why did you choose not to get married
well and actually i'm glad you asked
that because i kind of wanted to respond
to the gentleman behind you i'm sorry i
didn't get your name but he he had
mentioned you know there should be
consequences what have you um i feel
that today things are so different and
you know in my situation i
i wanted to get married he did not want
to get married and it's not something
that you can really force on somebody he
just is one of those people that just
doesn't want to make that long-term
commitment so in my situation you know
we're trying to do the right thing raise
the children together and then of course
you know we grew apart so we
separated but it i for my children's
sake i thought it would be better for
them to grow up in a household with a
traditional
situation but in my situation he was
unwilling to get married so it was
nothing i could could control and so
when he was saying you know maybe there
should be consequences but it's and i
agree with that because i i wish more
people would get married but i feel like
there's
so many things that are so different in
today's day and age that
it's harder and harder for people to
feel
safe if you will about getting married i
think there's been so many horror
stories out there about horrible
divorces there's infidelity there's all
these things so i think it scares people
and so it puts a lot of people in a
situation like myself where there was
nothing i could do because i couldn't
seeing your hands raised i'm going to
thank the witness for her testimony okay
are there any members of the public who
are in attendance who wish to testify
that have not testified already
seeing no hands raised
will now close the
public hearing
okay
we are now blessed with the presence of
the next hearing's not till not till 10
o'clock
just uh well i got everyone here
when we have just to make sure when we
do our committee reports
even if we want we won't mention which
bill this was
representative bradley probably
remembers if if i if i sign off on the
report and even if i sign off on it you
may want to just double check to make
sure that
the staff got that sign off because
there was a very well written report
although against what i wanted
it nevertheless didn't make it into the
calendar it was just a clerical
oversight but i know everyone works so
hard and diligent on their reports
and we would hate for that to happen
again so
we tried to just it never hurts the
what do you what do you mean follow up
with staff because if we send
the blurb to the chair and the
administrator that
as far as i know that is uh all we need
to do
you are correct but i'm just saying
no there is always the possibility of
human error
i i know that's surprising to hear that
i
i may make a mistake or someone else may
make a mistake but
due to a just pure clerical oversight
said report didn't make it into the
calendar
so it to avoid that mistake it never
hurts to just follow up
to confirm it 100 that's all i'm saying
you don't have to and there's no it's up
so mr chair how do we find out whether
or not the report has made it into uh
where it needs to go
i would assume
obviously you won't know until the
calendar comes out but i would assume
that
you can just ask for a confirmation a
confirmation email hey did this
did you perceive it
if i literally attach the person to the
email
and maybe
we'll try to encourage your response but
it can it's just
throwing it out there
do you always try to respond
to people when they're when their report
is approved
i i usually i tried to attach them i may
occasionally forget to hit reply all but
literally everyone's on the email thread
but i'm just saying it happened and
whether it's on my ultimates my
responsibility so it's
i take responsibility for it i'm just
trying to avoid happening again and i'm
just saying for that for the members it
would never hurt to
follow up it's just just a suggestion
it's not a rule
follow up
representing me i'm just i meant that
injustice
i would advise members to make sure that
their report
is in the report and and
see if they have any questions probably
before it gets into the
the calendar
so for there was one in time a while ago
where
a report was severely truncated and i
didn't realize what it was so just check
what you sent to make sure that
if there's something wrong with it when
you when it's put in there that
you have an opportunity to correct it
we will be in the committee will be in
just making sure everyone's here
at this time we will now open the
executive session on
senate bill 291
uh the chair recognizes representative
rose to make a motion thank you mr
chairman i move itl on senate bill 291
second second
that has been seconded by uh
representative
do you have a parliamentary inquiry or
well i just wanted to speak against the
inexpediential i just like
i if if
representative antelopes if you don't
mind if i just let representative rhodes
open since she made the motion and then
i'll recognize you thereafter
representative rhodes you recognize the
speak on the motion thank you mr
chairman a few things one
i know that we are not in control of
what bills
that we hear in our committee but i am a
little bit confused why this wouldn't be
in um
family law but that's that
um
and secondly i'm
you know there's a lot of things we
heard from the testimony that i can
certainly sympathize
with the young lady and but i also do
realize that
you know a lot of these things are out
of the control of legislator and i do
know that
you know you if you put both of your
names on as an example a checking
account because that was mentioned
anybody that has their name on a joint
checking account can can clean that
account out at any time regardless of
what their their marital status is
um or their living arrangement
furthermore i'm i'm still a little bit
confused on exactly what it is that
that they want to study and um other
than you know protecting your own assets
in a legal way i'm not really sure that
there's much much more that can be found
representative pandolakis you're
recognized
well first off i'd like to say that
we're all preaching this as a free state
so if you didn't want to get married you
shouldn't have to get married but you
should be protected and this is what she
is asking for is protection
protection and guidelines
like we have for married couple
i know of a couple they were gay but
that's beside the point
that the woman went to the hospital
they had lived together for 30 years
the daughter did not like
what had happened
but the other woman that lived the woman
passed away the one that lived she lost
everything
she didn't even know her name was on the
house they found a way to sell it
and so it's need they need protection
they they have that now
in the gay community but we don't have
it out there
in the community that says if i don't
want to marry somebody
he can still clean out my bank account
if i'm stupid enough to put both both
names on it so
i think we ought to nothing's going to
do any harm to really
uh study this and find out what really
is happening
no need to apologize representative
uh we'll just
representative speak to you
thank you mr chair and i you know i
agree with my colleague from portsmouth
i um
you know i think i think there's use in
in studying um the
you know
unmarried cohabitants and you know
domestic partnerships i think and more
and more we're seeing that folks are
getting married at a younger at an older
age and um especially my generation i
know that i got married after being in a
relationship for five years um which
might have been for had not been for
covet but um but the thing was you know
we um i i think a big part of the issue
is
these folks are you know
they care a lot about each other it's
really hard to discuss some of the
issues find especially financial issues
with your partner and when you're not in
that in that um
in a full like you know in a marriage um
it you know becomes even more difficult
but you know when you add kids into the
mix it becomes even more difficult um so
i i think that there is there is used to
studying um you know making sure that we
if if there are protections that need to
be added if there aren't protections
that need to be added um but at the end
of the day it's a study committee and
you know i think it's i think it's worth
the time for of the legislator to study
it
representative muse
yes i'd like to just to echo
representative expedia's comments and
one of the other things i wanted to do
too is just
point out the fact that one of the
things that we are trying to do in this
state pretty desperately is to attract
young people to live here
and i think you know when you're a lot
of the people that we're trying to
attract are probably in these types of
relationships they haven't made the
decision to get married yet
um and the fact that we we don't have uh
some of these protections you know could
be
uh could potentially be a show stopper
for them um
it's just a study committee you know
this is not a
uh
this this bill does not include any
proposed changes to law
uh it really just
you know
it's a it's a bill that would allow a
group of people to take a look at the
data to talk to more people to get a
clearer picture of where the problems
exist and where they don't exist and try
to develop some targeted solutions that
will help
not only help these people but also help
new hampshire become more attractive to
representative roy
thank you mr chairman
three issues
first and not the least of which we are
inundated with study committees um so we
have to be very judicious on on what we
choose to study
this particular issue when we legalize
same-sex marriage
it was for exactly this purpose so that
the people in these marriages would have
protections
so
they do have protections it's under the
law it's it's marriage that's how you
get into it to protect your assets other
than you know the moral and religious
aspects of why you want to get married
it provides distinct legal protections
second of all or third of all lastly the
um
prenuptial agreements
married couples can enter them and so
can non-married couples
if you get into a relationship you can
get
what is in fact a prenup but it's a
contract where you say this is mine this
is yours if we split this happens
so there's already in-law mechanisms and
tools to use to protect assets
and i just don't think that this is a
good use of our time to study something
that's already
protected if you just do a little
research on your own
thank you mr chairman
i'd like to point out just a couple of
things
in in the ladies testimony
for one she pointed out that in law
children have rights they we've done
bills and we've produced laws to protect
children no matter whether it's in a
cohabitating or in a marriage situation
so i thought that was enlightening
secondly she said i'm living in a
one-room apartment at one point
and then later in her testimony she
talked about having in a house
so i'm going
okay
so she hasn't as
bad office she tried to portray herself
is the state
gonna waste time and money
on another as my fellow representatives
said another study committee
and last but not least
when is the state ever want to get into
protecting the people that
don't want to protect themselves in the
very beginning and yet at the end come
back and say oh i need protection i need
protection
should have had that before you thought
before you got into it thank you mr
chairman and i will be voting
i've read a couple of things that if we
look at the law and research it will
understand why we should vote itl
we heard the first testimony about this
bill 45 minutes ago
so i'm unsure of what the laws are here
in new hampshire about
checking accounts i know from experience
with someone who's divorcing in florida
that a joint account in a divorce at
least there may be here
and you can divorce if you're married
that then
the
assets in that account
is noted
and
at least there are some protections
about where they can split whatever is
left in a joint account because that
legal thing is going on so we had a
woman come in here
and someone used the word betrayed
what her situation was her situation was
what it is
she had a one-room apartment
took her three years with the kids to
get a house don't know what kind of
house it is
don't know what their life what the
children's lifestyle was before that
and in a divorce
they not only consider child support
they also take a look at
the
salary of each party
and determine
whether there's equity in that
and that's where you get the alimony
thing so part of that is to be able to
make sure that the children if they
split and they live in two houses have a
similar kind of lifestyle
in both of those situations
but anybody
that doesn't have isn't married or
according to
some testimony for other members
that same-sex people
have protection
well
this was a situation that we heard the
testimony on and the testimony was
that this woman with her kids obviously
at least in my opinion from her
testimony
was that they do not have the same
standard of living and if she were
divorced
and she had
the ability to be able to rely on the
divorce laws
she would have a much more equal
situation
and so i'm worried about the kids
and i don't care what the founders said
about it
you know divorce was never a popular
thing until 50 years ago but now it is
so we should be concerned about what's
happening now
so giving given that what i've heard
representative conley mr chairman minus
a question
um i guess of you
we're in the second year of a two-year
term
um and i understand that there's some
hesitancy to uh seat
study committees in the second year of a
term in fact i ran against that
when my party was in the majority so i
guess i'm curious is this even
practically and logistically possible
representative marston please
you're recognized for your point of
representative morrison do you may you
turn on your microphone please
apologize
no deference to the person that made the
motion but if i'm not correct i'd like
to be aware of that that a person who is
not a permanent member of the committee
cannot make a motion
on a bill
thank you for staying in point of order
uh two things number one when a point of
order is raised it has to be raised
immediately the motion has been
already
it's been intervening business shall we
say so it's not timely to the but just
to clarify for the members of the public
and members of the committee
representative rhodes is now a permanent
member of the committee
so that my understanding is uh she
actually that member would be permitted
to make
motions
representative collins may you ask the
same question or i think you're asking
it the practicality of of this given
it's the second year
my understanding this is my humble
opinion alone
this would be reported out
before november 1st of 2022 so it could
the committee would conclude need to
conclude its work by then
so it would be able to perform its
function uh in
although we have a lot of commissions
and committees study committees and all
that i get that
i think if the topic or issues
you know if we as a body believe is
worthy of study and in need of study
then it's
okay to put forward i personally i i
don't
i understand that and i sympathize for
the testimony we received today but all
the issues raised are
are or could have already been addressed
under
the current law
and when you put money into a joint
account especially someone who is
refusing to commit to a long-term
relationship
i think that
in fairness
that's a red flag
and we're not here to give financial
if you want to keep protect your assets
you keep them separate especially if
you're not married that's
i mean i so i'm not really sure what
what problem we would need to fix is not
already fixable under the existing law
and any changes we make
we if we start going down that road the
reason why they abolished common law
marriages was that people who cohabitate
together
for a certain period of time even if
they're just roommates and living
separate i mean there's arguments to be
made
you know they want their marriage to be
clear whether parties are married or not
because then if you live with someone
for a couple years and you separate then
you go and get married through an
official ceremony did you was your first
long-term cohabitation i mean
a lot of that was discussed and worked
out over you know a century of
litigation
so just we might be going backwards this
is my humble opinion
representative representative boardney
thank you mr chairman
actually uh as far as
assets and a checking account are minor
to what really are the issues
we are looking at
assets like
houses
retirement plans
those are important assets
so
if we make someone incident because they
no longer don't have
at
access to these assets
that
reflects on
the state and the state has to take care
of incident people
so i think that there are some
good things to
discuss about this committee
and i think that
i'm not going to support the itl motion
representative pantologist and after
that we'll move the question
thank you mr chairman
in my day and age if you lived with some
one you had a red scarlet letter on you
and you couldn't do it
but nowadays it's a common thing
and we here at the state as
representatives
are here to protect everybody
and we say freedom every day
well freedom is the right to do what you
choose to do and i think this woman
brought up a lot of good points that
needed to be looked at
from the health insurance to the
retirement system and i would hope that
we would look at it and
study it
and maybe help her
representative expedia this time it's
really the last it is really quick um
only five percent of married people have
at this time when i'll move the question
if you're in support of the motion of
inexpediting to legislate please say yay
if you were opposed
please say nay the clerk will now call
the roll vice chairman roy yes
representative welch
yes representative burt
yes representative rhodes yes
representative greene
yes clerk votes yes representative
testerman yes
representative true yay
representative pratt yes representative
marston yes representative harriet
gathright
representative panolakis
representative o'hearn
representative bordenay
no
representative muse
no representative ray newman
no
representative conley
yes
representative bradley
no
representative espitia no
jamin abbas
chair votes yes
wait you did not call my name
i don't know who oh my mistake
representative schultz
no
and you're filling in for
bolden yeah
twelve
eight
by a vote of 12 to eight the motion of
index being to legislate passes
representative muse will be preparing
the minority report
it's the roads the majority report
this time when i'll close the executive
at this time we will now open the
public hearing on senate bill 292
requiring notice of arrest to a
probation
and parole officer
the committee now calls senator reagan
to introduce the bill
good morning
mr chairman and members of criminal
justice and public safety i'm senator
john reagan from senate district 17
and i bring to you today senate bill 292
that requires notice of arrest to a
probation and parole officer
and it's at the request of the
yes
representative perry garth right
um the 72 hours
my understanding is if i understood the
bill correctly
does not start until the county
person has notified
the probation office or parole officer
correct
whereas now today if someone's arrested
excuse me
i don't have an answer for him
representative marston
thank you mr chairman
thank the senator for
his testimony but that's just an
introduction of the bill i'd like to do
a little follow-up with you well how
about with the department of corrections
folks
are they here to testify
representative marston and i'll delay
and wait till then and just the members
of the community understand when there's
any member of the public or a member of
either body testifying
it's we're asking questions not making
statements so just keep it at that
if that continues you you'll be deemed
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee my name is bob oxley and i'm
the director of field services for the
department of corrections
and we'd like to thank senator reagan
for uh helping us with with this bill
um
we sent a copy of my statement and
i just pat
excuse me handed one out
i'll be very brief as it stands right
now
when a individual is arrested on one of
our warrants
we have 72 hours from the time they're
arrested
for no fault to the county systems
it's fallen through the cracks at times
and we haven't been notified in a timely
manner so that 72 hour clock has already
began to run and at times when we're not
notified in time
we're up against the wall trying to get
it done in time and we're coming from
all over the state to make it happen
this this simple change would just put
the onus on the superintendent of the
county facilities
to notify us
as soon as they can and then the 72 hour
clock would start running once the
probation pro officer is notified
and i'd be happy to answer any questions
representative roy you recognized for a
question thank you mr chairman uh thank
you for taking my question over here
that's right um
i'm not if you could explain to the
committee how it works i i know in
massachusetts
if anyone runs a record check a bop
border parole
probation check it automatically flags
the parole probation officer that
someone's looking at one of their guys
we don't have a similar system in new
hampshire
thanks for the question no sir we do not
it's up to you
it's up to the individual police officer
or the facility to notify us
would it not be better for us to do
something similar where you would get an
automatic hit that someone had run a
record on one of your guys
certainly we'd love to have that
i'm sure we could talk to the ncic folks
and maybe set something up and talk to
massachusetts as well that'd be a great
representative conley thank you mr
chairman thanks for your testimony what
is i heard the word notify many times
can you clarify what exactly would be
required to satisfy this bill
it would just be notification to the
probation parole officer we also have
the 24-hour
24 7 control room at the men's prison
as soon as they were notified they would
then contact the probationary officer if
it's off hours so it's just the
notification to the ppo
that their individual had been arrested
okay
representative burt
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony um the superintendents
i don't see
a dozen of them behind you opposing this
so i'm assuming they're okay with it
i believe so sir we talked to the
superintendents and met with their
committee um to discuss this and
they asked in the first go around for an
amendment and uh
they're on the same page with us at this
point
representative harry gathered
okay
i guess my the same question that i had
for the senator
so
if
say someone's arrested today
so at that point they know that that
person um
um is on parole or probation or whatever
so today the 72 hours start today
correct
yes ma'am all right
so follow up
follow up thank you um all right so
with this new bill
or um
as i understand it it it the 72 hours
would not start until the probation
officer is notified
which more than likely will not be that
day
and let's say someone got arrested in an
evening okay so that person is probably
going to stay where they are to the next
day
before they go to valley street or
somewhere else
um so
for me
you're detaining a person
okay
longer than necessary
and it sounds like there's a problem
with
how you guys do business
who notifies who and what have you so
now you're making it so in my opinion
that
and let me and tell me if i'm correct
that there could possibly be even a
longer 72 hours
did i ask the question
i'm not i'm not sure there was a it was
uh i think the concern is representative
i think the concern you're trying
raising is if a person is arrested
on parole
can that person still be held long in
the 72 hours absolutely that's it
because of someone because perhaps
even even by accident failed to provide
i'm sorry
i think
so the 72 hours would start as soon as
the probation parole officers notified
as you mentioned earlier if they were
arrested today
it would be on the superintendent of
that county jail to notify us and that's
when the clock would start that 72 hour
clock for us to get into the preliminary
hearing
if the chairs may inquire with the
question what would happen in a
situation where
for whatever reason a
person they forgot to give notice
i
i guess my concern is if or even if they
intentionally didn't give notice
wouldn't that
hold up to 72 hour clock and
going i understand there may be some
civil rights issues there but at the
same time in the short term
what would happen in that scenario
if once the 72 hour clock is expired
then
um
they would be released from that county
facility
if i can just ask a follow-up and thank
you for taking my question but my my
question is if someone never
provides a notice the 72-hour clock
would never start
so correct sir
so what would happen in a scenario and
i'm not saying this is happening but
let's just say a police officer decide
not to
transmit that notice
what what would be the result of that
if we were not notified that they were
um arrested or detained
that 72 hour clock would never start so
after 72 hours we would have to uh that
thank you
representative marston
thank you very much mr chairman
i'm a little confused but yet i can read
and follow the right written word this
is all in regards to somebody who has
been previously arrested
how does this all fall into place with
somebody who's
being arrested who's never been arrested
before is not on probation is not a have
a parole officer
that wouldn't have an impact on it sir
this is only for the folks
that are under on parole and they've
been arrested on a parole warrant
follow-up mr chairman
representative martin you recognized for
a follow-up
so in that case with a person who's
never been arrested within 72 hours
no sir for any charge outside of the
parole violation i'm i'm not sure what
the timeline is on a regular charge this
is just
pertaining to a parole violation thank
you
representative pandolakis
thank you mr chairman
um
have they ever notified the parole
officers before
the superintendents
yes ma'am that's how it works currently
and as as i made mentioned in my written
statement there's just been times no
fault to the jails as far as malice or
trying to avoid notifying us
there's been delays
in notifying us at times
for whatever reason that the county
facilities backed up or administrative
rules that they have
it's just
the clock starts a little longer once
we're notified but they do currently
notify us
representative bourdain
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question i really have a very
simple question
when someone is arrested
and it is a pro-e how did the how is
they're arrested on that parole warrant
so if
as an example if you were stopped on the
street and they ran your name it would
come back as a parole hit so the officer
would then arrest you on that parole
warrant and in that readout it would say
who the pro officer is and they should
follow representative board name so in
this case and so all perles are in a
database so that when an officer arrest
someone their name would come up if they
were on parole yes sir thank you very
much
i just i just have maybe you can clarify
uh something that you said for me
um you talked about a control center
available
24 hours a day seven days a week
um
and here it says so if you're notified
there
um
that there that it would be 72 hours and
it also includes saturday sundays and
holidays so that 72 hours could be
longer when they're notified is that
correct
yes sir yes that does not include
weekends and holidays
representative tessman
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
how many times does this happen i mean
is this
once or twice a year 10 or 20 times a
year
you know your your estimate of how many
times per year this happens
thank you sir it's not often i couldn't
put a number on it i've been the
director of field services for a little
under three years now
it has not happened often but the few
times that it has happened that's when
would this proposed statute uh
apply to people who have been convicted
of
or of uh of violent crimes uh only or
does this apply
to non-violent offenses as well
thank you sir it would be for any
violation that
that the parole had the warrant states
on it so it could be any violation not
representatives you recognize for a
follow-up
given your experience
my guess is you've had
you've had some
at least anecdotal experience with how
the current system is working
how long typically does it take
you know for this notification
uh to take place uh
currently without this bill
thank you for the question honestly i i
don't have a precise answer to that
i'm not on the street with the ppos but
i can definitely uh
representative museum recognized for a
follow-up yes would you agree that um
it's important to have an answer for
that question because uh that would be
the amount of time
that uh would get that could potentially
get added to the 72 hours
which means
we would be able to quantify
the amount of the additional amount of
time
somebody might be held in jail if
there's a late notification
in
if i understood the question
i'm sorry could you repeat the question
i i'm the one who didn't get much sleep
last night
so i'll try to i'll try to be a little
bit uh
um
i'll try to be a little bit clearer but
from from the sounds of it
um
this is something that you have
experience with now
parole officers are no are
are notified when when possible um
and i guess what i was asking is based
on your your current experience and the
fact that we really don't have data for
this yet
i'm a little stuck trying to quantify
you know are we talking about maybe
82 hours for some people are we talking
about a hundred i'm just wondering with
the clock not starting until the parole
officer is notified
um
whether we might have something like a
habeas corpus issue going on here thank
you sir
the
it is not a common thing as i mentioned
earlier with the other question it's not
a common thing i don't know the exact
time frame that it takes to be notified
but i know it's not normally an issue
they're usually done in a timely manner
and
we're just trying to make sure that
we're notified in a timely manner and
then the clock could stop start excuse
me
representative welch
thank you mr chairman
uh
it's my understanding that
the
facility at the men's prison
that's available 24 7.
once that phone call from the
correctional facility goes in doesn't
that start it isn't that the same as
notifying the probation officer yes sir
when they're when they when the
individual is arrested it states right
on the paperwork to notify the probation
parole officer or off hours that contact
prison control
thank you
representative conley
thank you sir for taking the question so
forgive me if this was addressed or if
this is obvious but
what happens to the individual are they
picked up and brought back to prison
like what is the process that's
triggered
from this notification working as it's
intended and and also what happens if
the person is then released can they
just be picked up again can you answer
those in one fell swoop please
they with it within that 72 hours they
have to be presented in front of a judge
unless they waive a hearing so
once they're notified they have 72 hours
to actually have that preliminary
hearing
a majority of the time they usually
waive that preliminary hearing
um
but that's that's what we're looking to
accomplish
thank you for your testimony of the
chairman choir for question and thank
you for taking my question
we hear that term 72 hours comes up
it came up in almost every question
my question is is when someone is
taken into custody whether they're a
parolee or it's for a probation
violation
do you know
approximately how long is it that person
actually in custody for
close to the 72 hours i'm not talking
about weekends and holidays i get that's
that's still an issue from the time
we're notified if i understand it yes
i think it was similar
i don't have the exact number of or how
but
it's usually not an issue
where it's gone
beyond the 72 hours
it's become a problem for us when we're
notified late in that 72-hour clock
that we then have to struggle to try and
and if i mask involve upon being
notified
what
what's approximately how much time would
it take to have someone in custody
brought for a hearing
i understand sorry sir
once we're notified we do it almost
immediately
representative newman
thank you i i have
a question about you mentioned uh
arrested on a parole
parole
or probation warrant or maybe that not
too maybe just you said parole warrant
so i'm i'd like to hear more about what
exactly that is and i'll just give an
example that you might want to
differentiate
is there a difference between being
arrested on a parole warrant and a
parolee being arrested for dwi for
example
thank you for the question yes yes sir
there is
so once you're placed on parole
you have to live within certain
guidelines and restrictions if you
violate any of those restrictions then
the parole officer would then
write for a warrant to be signed by the
parole board
if someone was out on parole and got
arrested for some other charge say dwi
that would be a separate charge
we would then probably move to make a
violation and have a pro warrant issued
represent newman recognized for a
follow-up
so in relation to your answer
someone who is on parole or probation
gets a dwi that they would be subject to
the laws that is
that applied to someone who has just
been arrested for that
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
the witness for his testimony thank you
are there any members of the public who
are present who wish to testify that
have not testified already please raise
your hand
seeing none at this time we will now
close the public hearing
in
um
this time we'll now call the order the
the criminal justice and public safety
committee
this time when i open the public hearing
on senate bill
293 establishing a committee to clarify
the intent of rsa 644 colon 9
relative to the violation of privacy
and the committee now calls senator
james gray
thank you very much my name is james
gray i am the senator representing
district six
which starts in rochester goes up route
11 to alton barnstead and gilmanton
this bill
has its
origin
many years ago and we haven't been able
to to get it through covet has caused a
problem
uh but imagine that you are an
individual
and
somebody records your voice
unintentionally
now suppose that you are an individual
and somebody records you
with video and no voice
in some state of undress is that a
misdemeanor or a felony
and what you'll find out
the first one's a felony and the second
one is a misdemeanor
that's
we've had people testify in private pre
prior years that
gee this is going to
take away people's rights
because we're going to have some
progressive justice
we've had people
testify that gee we need more time to
study this whole issue
we've had lots of different testimony so
the good senate committee took uh
what my suggestion was and
uh progressive justice
and turned it into the bill that you see
in front of you now
i want to tell you that in
stratford county
one of the individuals that caused this
invaded a home
got into bed with an individual
and why
because we didn't do a good job
of having the laws protect that
individual
that's where we need to go
so are you asking essentially the
uh the lawmakers to go back and on a
case-by-case basis
and say this goes with that this goes
with this
uh
yeah or is that something that you know
the attorney general or
could go through and say you know this
goes with that i mean uh is it we have a
difference of opinion of where what
we're
trying people
or just this is what we think i guess
i'm
and we've got an attorney general and a
whole
bunch of really smartest lawyers in the
world who can figure this
out the as far as i know the law is very
clear
in both of the cases that i
set before you
the senate committee which
since the senate position is the
position
that i am here to support
wanted a study committee
certainly i want you to know that there
was an opportunity
to do something with the law itself
and not the study committee but again
right now i'm
going to support the senate
and
that if we have a study committee and
the committee comes forth that will be
another reason why
uh that we as legislators should
make whatever change the study committee
says
representative burt
thank you mr chairman thank you for you
know taking my question uh i'm looking
at
644 colon 9 right now
i see where the class a misdemeanor is
where is the class
where's the felony charge
i didn't bring the copies of the statute
with me
uh but that's what i was informed by
several people including the chief of
okay thank you
oh could i have a follow-up
representative burt you recognize for a
follow-up thank you oh
so are you
hoping that the committee you know the
study committee will come out with a
felony charge for these or are you
looking
just to study to see where it should be
i believe that
a person who re records a video of you
in a state of undress
uh is more severe than
uh recording your voice without your
permission
uh with no other
and that that penalty should be equal to
or greater than
the recording of your voice
thank you for your testimony
senator is excused
um good morning mr chair and members of
the committee my name is pamela keilig
and i am the public policy specialist at
the new hampshire coalition against
domestic and sexual violence um the
coalition is the umbrella organization
for our 12 community-based crisis
centers that serve
about 15 000 survivors of domestic and
sexual violence through our free and
confidential services each year
we're here to speak in support of sb 293
which would establish a study committee
to review and clarify
new hampshire's violation of privacy
statute as you heard
from the senator rsa 644-9
we believe that changes to the statute
need to be made to ensure that it is
adequately protects individuals against
sexual exploitation and abuse
and we think that this could be the
appropriate vehicle to explore
you know what those changes could be
and especially make it consistent with
other interrelating statutes violations
of privacy can be co-occurring with acts
of stalking sexual assault domestic
violence and child exploitation and can
have extreme emotional and psychological
impacts on a victim moreover violations
of privacy are often indicators of
lethal intent and even escalating
violence
so they should be seen as serious crimes
and co-occurring crimes
studying rsa 6449 would help ensure that
the statute is updated and that any
future legislation would align with
those interrelating statutes that i
briefly mentioned some of those are rsa
645 1 lewdness and indecent exposure
the endangering and welfare of a child
statute rsa 6
certain uses of computer services
rsa 649b4
and obscene matter rsa 656502
all of those statutes if one is changed
could have unintended consequences on
another statute if the whole picture
isn't viewed so we really ask that the
study commission or we believe that the
study committee is really important
because it will give us the opportunity
to really interrogate those statutes and
and create thoughtful legislation
and so i think with that i just asked
the committee to please consider
supporting this bill and making sure
that we respond appropriately to these
crimes and that the appropriate changes
are made in the future thank you and i
representative burt
thank you mr chairman thank you for your
testimony
how many um so looking at the 649
644.9 yep uh
how many cases have been
prosecuted
each year and how many have been found
guilty of this this misdemeanor crime
that possibly could grow to a felony
charge
yeah no thank you so much for your
question representative i don't have the
statistics offhand um but i'd be happy
to look into that for you i do know that
between the statutes that i listed and
this statute
prosecutors and members of law
enforcement often have to be creative in
terms of applying it because
there's
because of the way they speak to each
other
and i think there's ways that we can
clarify what's in the statute to make
sure that it's very clear what the
intent is and what those what a
violation of privacy actually means and
representative muse
yes thank you for taking my question
and i'll try to peek around
representative bordenay's head here uh
so uh i can see you are there specific
gaps uh in the statute
uh
that uh that you're looking to address
or that you would like the committee to
address
um we don't have a specific proposal in
mind um i do know that in the past three
legislative sessions um bills have been
introduced to explore
you know what happens if someone
repeatedly violates these things like
three or more times and it's always a
misdemeanor level we're not saying that
that's necessarily the proposal but
that's something that has been looked at
in the past
but i think the question here is just
you know
what are these crimes and and how
invasive they are and how um they are
often indicative of further violence um
and are is the statute really doing uh
what it needs to do in response to those
crimes
representative rhodes
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so um
i'm looking at
um under section 6449
a um and then
in section two c it says
about a person with like un unsolicited
images under c
it says that the per like knows or
should have known that the person in the
image has not consented to
his is not basically he's not consented
to it so would that
already not
not be in the law or am i
[Laughter]
yeah as i was reading maybe i'm
misunderstanding it but would that not
already is that not already covered
under the under the law under that
section
sorry i missed it okay so section one um
so it is
uh section 644 nine
and then it is under section two
and then it's a one two
and then b's oh my god c it's really
the copy i have doesn't align with that
just to clarify i think you're you're
reading from 644
colon9-a where this study committee
would only apply to 644 colon 9. okay
but that's already that's what i'm
saying
this section is what what the study
commission would be yeah it's already a
i haven't read that far yet
i did
to answer your question
partially i think um i think this is why
we need to have these conversations and
why it's worth having a study committee
because i think
what i've noticed
in you know my two years here serving in
my role is that oftentimes
an amendment or an amendment to a
statute will come in but it will not
have looked at the larger picture um and
so we have sort of a patchwork of um
a statute here that has like oh you know
this needs to be covered under that but
then maybe it was already partially
covered under another one uh for example
um
you this committee
passed or
voted to pass
a bill on unsolicited intimate images
and a previous iteration of that
legislation
actually had been placed in rsa 649
644 9 i believe
and the
recent bill that passed this committee
was actually put into 64 45 1 which is
the lewdness and indecent exposure
because
there was discussion around maybe that
was the most appropriate place and so i
think there has been a bit of confus or
i don't want to say confusion but i
think a conversation is warranted to
make sure that when we update these
statutes the intent is very clear and
that we aren't um
confusing other statutes or
creating unintended consequences so that
they everything speaks really nicely in
harmony with each other
i'm not a lawyer though i want to
clarify
so
in your testimony so far and i might not
would it be
fair to uh
say that you you're looking at
you mentioned 645 you mentioned 645
9 you mentioned
all these numbers
of different bills
so would it be fair to say that that
you're looking at somebody to take a
look a big picture look at all of those
bills that deal with privacies including
the definitions of the penalties and all
of those kind of things
to
make a better set of laws that that
address privacy
yeah i i think
sp 293 is that vehicle to start looking
at this particular statute rsa 6449
violations of privacy
but i guess our
my
point is just that
because
it's important to recognize that this
statute would have
impacts on others under other related
statutes so that's why i think it's
important to study this so that we
like are looking at the full picture
representative newman you recognize for
follow-up could i make a question to the
chair
the parliamentary inquiry you recognize
um
my reading of this bill
and a study committee says that the
report has to be made by november 1st so
what happens you can't go over
the election
but there are some study committees that
that go on
indefinitely and i don't know if that's
a different kind of study committee but
could you just comment on
on the problem with the date and the
difference between study committees if
it depends on what what the proposed
bill
says now you can have this has a
deadline of when it has to be
a final report needs to be made
and then upon the final report being
made that that's when it's concluded
now
if
some some
study committees or commissions they can
go on
indefinitely
the downside to that is that those
commissions or committees are kind of
just they're just out there they're open
they're not active
the idea is
there's a deadline when they want this
to be submitted by now
i understand there's a filing period
i know it's it's different depending on
which body you're in but for
members of the house my understanding is
if you're already a member of the house
right now there's some filing period
that can occur in september
obviously i presume this report wouldn't
be done by then but
there's also a second filing period i
don't remember the exact dates but it's
in december
so there would be time to
um review that whatever the study
committee's report is
just a follow-up yes
so
the writers of this bill could they have
by changing the date
extended into the next session
they could it's whatever the intent is
of the drafter they they can put they
can put you know 20 25. you know
november 1st 2025 the problem with that
is that without a final report any
benefits of that
study the some of the legislators that
next term
would not have the benefit of whatever
whatever that committee learned or
gathered so the idea is this is
something that i believe
needs
to be addressed and the goal would be to
address it
in the first year of next term is my
intent of that short deadline
of my interpretation of that should i
return to my follow-up with the witness
yes thank you
so
given the discussion we just had
um and
i don't know how big or little you think
the time period would be to accomplish
whatever your goals are with a study
committee
um do you do you have any comments about
the discussion we just had about the
date of november of november the first
this year
yeah um i would um thank you so much for
your question i would definitely leave
that up to you all um in the legislature
in terms of that because i believe a
study committee only is made up of
legislators and isn't a broader
commission um so
i would you know but we're happy to be a
resource um in answering any questions
moving forward if you do move forward
with the study committee thank you very
much
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
i am gathering from
this piece of legislation which is
asking for a study committee
that
we're not ready for prime time why is
this not being made into a law not a
study committee
yeah thank you so much for your question
representative
this um this bill was amended in the
senate to become a study committee
because of several pieces of legislation
that were introduced in 2022 to uh to
amend rsa 6449 and so rather than
taking on both of those pieces of
legislation they converted this bill
into a study committee because of um the
competing interest to make changes and
they wanted to make those changes
thoughtfully
that's my understanding thank you very
see no hands raised i want to thank the
witness for for her testimony thank you
are there any members of the public who
are present who wish to testify that
have not testified already
seeing no hands raised
this time we'll now close the public
hearing
at this time the committee will be in
recess to
so
this time the committee will come to
order
at this time
we will now open the public hearing
on senate bill 393 relative to the use
of restraints on pregnant women in the
custody of a state or county
the committee calls senator whitley
thank you thank you mr chair and good
morning members of the committee i have
not been before this committee this
session for the record my name is becky
whitley and i'm honored to serve new
hampshire senate district 15 which
includes the wonderful
communities of concord henneker
as a mother i'm honored to bring forth
today senate bill 393 which limits the
types of restraints used on pregnant
people who are incarcerated in new
hampshire jails and prisons
so as many folks may know shackling
pregnant women poses serious health
risks to both mom and to baby
you may have received testimony from
medical experts that say shackling poses
safety risks that include the potential
for injury or placental abruption caused
by falls delayed progress of labor
caused by impaired mobility and delayed
receipt of emergency care when
corrections officers must remove
shackles to allow for assessment or
intervention
it can also interfere with the ability
of people postpartum to safely handle
feed and bond with a newborn which as a
mom is one of the most precious points
of a baby's life
furthermore restraining women in
transport to prenatal care and during
delivery and labor can obstruct
necessary medical care and during labor
lead to extreme physical pain and
complications because of the mother's
inability to move freely
according to a 2017 report from the
american psychological association
and i will point out that anyone who has
given birth knows that a woman's ability
to harm others or flee during labor
is severely limited right uh both
you know it during labor during delivery
and of course postpartum uh is is a very
vulnerable time for women and you don't
have much control
women subjected to restraint during
childbirth birth also report severe
mental distress depression anguish and
trauma this is also from the 2017 apa
report that i mentioned previously
shackling during or immediately
following childbirth can cause
or exacerbate pregnancy-related mental
health concerns including depression and
post-traumatic stress disorder i think
it's important to point out that this
committee may be well aware that women
who are incarcerated tend to on average
have suffered many many more childhood
traumas
being shackled can increase
post-traumatic symptoms caused by prior
experiences of trauma and can of course
always also be re-traumatizing
national correctional and medical
associations oppose the shackling of
pregnant women because in most cases
it's unnecessary and of course dangerous
to the health of the mom and the baby
the nation's leading experts in maternal
fetal and child health care the american
congress of uh obstetrics
excuse me
obstetricians and gynecologists have
clearly stated their opposition to the
practice of shackling according to that
association acog shackling interferes
with the ability of physicians to safely
practice medicine
and is demeaning and unnecessary
so i i wanted to point your attention to
um two things
the bill uh that came over from the
senate was the result of
extensive cooperation
and collaboration between advocacy
organizations myself
and
from you know a lot of input from the
department of corrections and we heard
some concerns from counties so the
amended version did take into account a
lot of those concerns but i will say the
collaboration has continued so in front
of you you have
i hope you have amendment one three four
four everyone have that great so that is
again the result of continued
collaboration between all parties and um
you'll hear from the folks behind me
that can give you some more detail about
why they felt it was necessary to make
these changes but i do feel i'm
incredibly grateful for all the
advocates for the medical professionals
that worked incredibly hard to get this
bill where it is and to the department
of corrections for their work i i feel
that
this collaborative collaboration has
resulted in a bill that both protects
the safety of well-being of our moms and
babies but also of course
public safety and the safety of our
correctional officers it's a delicate
balance and i believe that this
amendment really strikes that delicate
balance so thank you for your
consideration i'm happy to take any
questions but i think the more technical
questions are better left for the people
representative pandalagas
thank you mr chairman i just wanted to
know if the amendment replaces the whole
bill
let's see um it replaces amend the bill
by replacing sections one and two
okay thank you
representative rory
thank you um for taking my question and
for bringing us the spill uh was there a
if you could tell me was there a an
incident or an impetus for this bill uh
coming from that that you brought at the
visioning product thank you for that
question so it was actually brought to
me by a number of advocates including
acog um new hampshire has a very robust
um
num a very robust society the acog those
are the obstetricians and the
gynecologists who you know in new
hampshire in fact you know it's a it's a
field that's really fraught right now
because there's not a lot of them and
you know it's a it's an area that in new
hampshire we're really trying to make
sure we get new ob gyns to new hampshire
but they raised the issue with me it was
also raised separately from advocates so
i don't think it's linked to a
particular incident but it's certainly
one that many folks have been thinking
long and hard about it
because it's such an important issue for
representative schultz
thank you mr chair haven't there been
incidents nationally where
pregnant women in uh jail or prison have
faced
safety concerns
because of um
these sorts of restraints thank you for
the question yes and acog actually does
have an extensive report on this issue
and i'm happy to send it to the
committee
thank you for your testimony if the
chair can may inquire with the question
and i'm referring to the
the amendment that you provide the
committee sure on the first page lines
to 15
it it says it references in the first
second or third trimester front
handcuffs only
is was there any
medical information or studies done on
the difference
which each trimester in having front
handcuffs supposed to
expose your hands behind the back
uh
you know you can sort of think about you
know when a woman
is pregnant their belly is expanding
right um
and so i think you know there are some
experts that can speak to that more in
particular why that was put into the
bill but yeah it's a medical indication
the majority of the bill was written
you know uh we started with what was you
know most appropriately medically and
then we you know the next phase of the
work was really to look about how to you
know balance what's necessary for mom
and baby and what's necessary for public
safety so there is a very delicate
balance thanks for that question
representative muse
another reason for uh handcuffing women
in the front would might that be
so the woman could protect herself in
the event of a fall
correct
it's seeing no hands raised i'm going to
thank thank you senator for your
testimony
thank you
hello and good morning
i am christy and i am a resident of new
hampshire and i also bring with me the
direct lived experience as a formerly
incarcerated woman so i have lived
handcuffed and shackled at various times
during my incarceration i can tell you
it's extremely uncomfortable has left
bruises and has been painful
i support this bill because i have lived
with pregnant women who were in
preparation to give birth
during their their time at the prison
i'm also a mother of three children and
i have experienced postpartum depression
with each of those three children
mothers should have the opportunity to
birth their children free of shackles
giving birth is an all-encompassing
endeavor which requires focus
the opportunity to move if needed and
most importantly the ability to hold
your baby for the first time a baby who
have you have carried inside of you for
nine months and this should be done so
without any added stress or anxiety
shackling a human being during birth or
in preparation for is not only excessive
it is cruel and unusual punishment for
the mother and the baby the pregnant
mothers who i met in prison were riddled
with fear and anxiety as they prepared
for this about the confinement and about
the imminent separation that they were
going to have from their baby
imagine these emotions passing through
the mother to their baby as they
prepared for birth
upon returning to prison after giving
birth these women oftentimes would
seclude themselves in their cells for
days or weeks sometimes curled in the
fetal position crying
obviously traumatized and devastated
from the overall experience
bringing life into this world is
extraordinary and each one of us in this
room were birthed from a mother and
impacted
from the moment we took our first breath
let us not
disturb this miracle with shackles thank
you
good morning members of the committee my
name is joseph lascaz
i will be representing the american
civil liberties union of new hampshire
in support of this legislation
the first thing that i just wanted to do
uh i just wanted to work my way
backwards actually and start answering a
couple questions that had been um
proposed and then work into it um
representative abbott talked about uh
the study of the front to back and
unfortunately the medical providers that
we worked with when um
researching this uh were are not able to
be here today because they are
taking care of community members at
various hospitals across the state but
what i did learn from them is that the
shackling it does present an issue
specifically with the increased use of
blood clots
for pregnant women
and the other issue happened to be with
the fact that the center of gravity is
actually changed
when an individual is pregnant so having
the front cuffs would be able to provide
the maximum amount of protection
for the resident when being transported
the medical community did want to make
sure that they that it was on record
that they they personally believe that
there shouldn't be any restraints um at
any point in time for
uh pregnant um residents and again if
they were able to be here today they
would um they would speak as to the
medical reasons why
with that being said this is this
amendment is something that
we can all support and
and go through with because it does
bring safety it balances safety of
the correctional institutions when
dealing with residents during transport
but it also
brings a medical benefit where it
decreases the use of blood clots it
allows
a resident to be able to safely move
around and as the humane aspect to it
where during delivery childbirth
and postpartum restraints wouldn't be
used
one thing that i do want to say that one
beneficial um
change to
the current
law
that i can speak to
personally is the fact that
security personnel are making medical
calls and this happened to me in 2012 i
had a torn rotator cuff and a dislocated
a visibly dislocated shoulder and a
security personnel decided to make a
medical
call that i should be restrained with
belly cuffs and my and behind my back
with that and that resulted in further
damage that had to be resolved at cmc
hospital so this takes care of those
type of situations by placing that call
back in the medical provider's hands and
i do think that this is something that
will move our state forward in equitable
practices
so with that i would conclude my
testimony i'm happy to take any
representative schultz
thank you mr chair i don't know if
you'll be able to answer this and maybe
someone else could after you
do you have an idea of how many
women
on average in a year are pregnant and
giving birth while incarcerated
in new hampshire in new hampshire
specifically that
in new hampshire for the county jails
and for the prison system combined the
number uh is is not um near the national
average but what i can say um
from
there is the number
it's since 1970 the number uh the number
has grown by seven fold um
that is what uh has that research has
come back from the medical providers um
that that are dealing with them in the
community
representative muse
thanks for taking my question um
can you just walk us through quickly um
i'm i i know that this is not
an uncommon situation in our state
prison
or our county jails
um but i'm curious what the current
standard operating procedure is and
whether it differs from county to county
and
or if it's consistent across the state
prison system
thank you very much representative muse
for that question uh it actually differs
and that is that is a problem that and
this will bring uniformity
several years ago we worked with the
department of corrections on on their
internal policy uh related to restraints
in incarcerated
pregnant residents
and they they had adopted um the best
practices at the time and since then we
have continued to work on on more
equitable equitable approaches and
bringing the medical community providers
that work in our state with these
residents bringing them into the
conversation has really highlighted some
ways that we can continue to improve
this
the process right now
and the way that it goes is
it it varies from from
county facility to county facility and
there are some that are that are that
are worse than others um specifically uh
valley street is is a county facility
where that
the application of this law would have
one of the biggest impacts to the
incarcerated residents there
for the way that
their transportation is done
so that yes there is significant changes
seeing no hands right i want to thank
the witness for his testimony
the committee now calls nikki plant new
for the record my name is nikki plant
i'm the warden at the new hampshire
correctional facility for women and i'll
be testifying on behalf of the
department of corrections
i'm melissa masso i'm the legislative
liaison for the department of
corrections and the commissioner would
have loved to be here today but she had
so if there are no questions before i
begin
with the proposed amendment presented
this morning by senator whitley
all of the written testimony that was
submitted prior to and any of the
concerns on the behalf of the department
of corrections have now been addressed
with the new proposal
with that said
the new hampshire department of
corrections is now in full support of
the new amendment to this legislation
as it balances the dignity of the
and to representative schultz's question
that we do have data only for the state
prisons on the back of that sheet
current through today
we would not be able to provide
and if the chair may inquire of a
question this is either one
either witness may answer this i
understand that initially you may have
been in opposition to this but now in
support can you explain what policy
changed in the proposed amendment that
would
cause that change in consideration
um the concerns presented by the
department of corrections were
in section two discussed transports
first second and third trimester as
front handcuff only
and if you went to the previous version
section three and section four
further described
that medical appointments for medicals
and transportation to courts required
absolutely no restraints
so it was a conflict
and some confusion regarding the
statement in section two and that was
thank you
representative conley
thank you mr chair thanks for taking the
question
could the department implement this
all the measures spelled out in this
bill
right now
sir the actual bill um is in line with
departmental policies as we exist and
we've been running for years
okay so you're already doing everything
that's clear that's in that is correct
representative rory
thank you
um a follow-up of my colleagues question
a new commissioner though could change
that's correct sir i think i would i
i see no hands right
excuse me representative marston
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question as it stands now
and on average how many pregnant women
are in your facility
so today i have zero sir
with the fyb 22 in this past budget
cycle
we had two one was paroled out and one
did
deliver while in custody
thank you
representative bourdain
thank you mr chair uh thank you for
taking my question
so after um
after she delivers
so that is for the duration of their
hospital stay
and so it's up to the hospital uh once
the resident is released from the
hospital she will return to the state
prison
and arrangements will be made prior to
through the hospital of where the baby
would go
quick follow-up
representative roy so generally speaking
one to two days would that be fair
without complications probably um
in addition the department offers
generally residents get two visits a
week
with an infant for the first i believe
it's at least eight months they get two
additional so they get four
opportunities to visit per week last
question please
um and just one more follow-up is there
a program in place for for women to be
able to deliver breast milk should they
choose to breastfeed to their infant or
no
so it has been done i would not say that
there's a program in place
it has been done so if there is a need
or if it's detrimental to the child in
the hospital deems that it is necessary
we make arrangements through our medical
staff to have that facilitated and
dropped off to the hospital themselves
thank you you're welcome
may i provide the witness with the
the letter from the department of
corrections that we just passed out if
you don't have a copy of it you have it
yes
okay so i have a question about i may
have now proceeded with my question
yes thank you
uh as i look at page one of the letter
um in the
the paragraph just above the last
paragraph or the the two words it says
the proposed legislation has written
does not align
with the current breast practices and
may impede the department's safety
does the amendment that i believe we
have correct that correct the
deficiencies that are mentioned in that
particular sentence yes it does sir
representative muse
thanks for taking my question uh one
thing i'm i'm a little curious about is
um
how the determination is made that a
that a woman is pregnant i know that
women who are farther along will be
obviously showing women who aren't
that far along though could be
at significant risk as well do you
depend on
on self-disclosure or is there any
process to identify
this when women are input into the
system um so it's actually determined by
our medical staff they will conduct
testing if necessary
senior hands-raised i want to thank the
witnesses for the testimony thank you
are there any members of the public
present who wish to testify that have
with no members of the public
wishing to testify at this time we'll
now
close the public hearing on senate bill
so
foreign
representative muse the chair may
inquire of a question
if
we were to hold an executive session on
senate bill 393
and we have an amendment
would you be inclined to make a motion
about to pass as amended and perhaps
i'm gonna hope the dean is quick to the
gun and
all right
at this time we will now open
the executive session on senate bill
this time the chair will recognize
mr chair i move uh amendment uh 13 uh 44
s to sb
uh 393. fn ought to pass
so the motion's ought to pass and wish
to offer an amendment and is there a
second oh that is the second by
and representative you wish to
speak to your motion
yes this is a situation um
that that most likely doesn't happen
extremely frequent frequently in our
system but i think
it's an area where i think we've heard a
pretty compelling case today to
um
uh to do something that protects women
and their and their children um
this is a um
this is a policy and a law that uh that
other states have um and this is one
that we need i i have uh i've heard
about some of the inconsistencies in the
county system
uh and the idea that we could actually
begin to address some of them
more consistently and we can put this
into statute so it becomes the law of
new hampshire
as opposed to just a policy
that can be changed at any time by a
by a new
commissioner of the department of
corrections i think is a very good thing
a lot of work has gone into not only the
bill itself
but also the amendment and getting all
of the parties to agree
that this is the way to go
and
[Music]
representative rory
thank you mr chairman
um
i agree with everything representative
you just said
there all the stakeholders seem to be on
board at the same time
um and and i i would i would go on a
limb and say that anyone who considers
themselves to be pro-life um
could not with a straight face not
support this bill so i will be voting
393.
um
this time at this time we'll now
move the question the motion is to
2022-1344 s if you're in support of
adopting the amendment please say yay if
you're opposed
please say nay the clerk will not call
the roll vice chairman roy yes
representative welch
representative burke yes representative
rhodes yes
representative greene
yes
clark votes yes representative testament
yes representative true yay
representative pratt yes
representative marston
yay
representative harriet gathright yes
representative panalakis
representative o'hearn representative
bordnay yes
representative muse
yes representative newman
yes representative schultz
yes representative conley yes
representative bradley yes
representative espitia yes chairman
abbas
chair votes yes
now the amendment's been adopted
representative wish to make a motion of
thank you mr chair i'd like to uh to
move amendment 1344 s ought to pass
motions out to pass as amended
represent them used to wish to speak to
your motion about to pass as amended
let's do it again
thank you
okay
at this time
no if any members wish to speak i see no
hands raised we can now move the
question
motion is ought to pass as amended
um you supported the motion please say
yay if you're opposed uh please say nay
the clerk will now call the roll
vice chairman roy yes representative
welch
representative burrick yes
representative rhodes
representative green yes
clerk votes yes representative testament
yes representative true yay
representative pratt yes representative
marston
yes
representative harriet gathright
representative panolakis
representative o'hearn representative
boardney yes
representative muse yes representative
newman
yes representative schultz yes
representative conley
representative bradley yes
representative espitia yes and chairman
abbas
will you prepare a majority report
at this time we'll now close the
executive session on senate bill
393.
uh
to the members of the community the
committee will be in
committee
foreign
and there is a mem there's been an
amendment that has been handed out to
representative welcome we should be
i offer an amendment to senate bill 293
seeing no hands raised the matter will
now be when i'll move the question if
you are in support of adopting amendment
number
2022-1348 h please say yay if you were
opposed
please say nay the clerk will not call
her all
vice chairman roy yes
representative welch
representative burt yes representative
rhodes yes representative greene
yes clark votes yes representative
testament yes
representative true yay
representative pratt yes
representative marston yes
representative harriet gathright
representative panolakis
representative o'hearn representative
bordening yes
representative muse
yes representative newman yes
representative bradley yes
representative espitia yes chairman
abbas
the chair votes yes
18-0
the
with the amendment my under
interpretation is
it would have been a study committee
consisting of one member of the
other body
in two members of the other body and
it just it changes them the uh makeup of
but i think the scope of what the study
committee would be doing
stupid but same there going to be
two members of the senate and one member
of ours yes
but in the
i'm just speaking for myself i think
that the topic of what the study
committee would look into in research is
worthy of studying we were on a
committee conference
i forget the bill number but i believe
is myself representative wallace and
representative rhodes and actually
another member of your
same caucus as representative
pantologist who's not a member of this
committee and
that involved the transmission of lewd
images
and during the committee conference it
was actually the sponsor of the bill
i believe
she's one of the representatives out of
nashua
noticed that we may have and it was not
intentional clearly not the intention of
the sponsor
that it would have actually
changed a penalty for you know
transmitting loot images of miners to a
so the idea of when they say potential
unintended consequences of other laws
when you try to fix something that was a
really good example of it and keep in
mind at the community conference this is
already passed in both bodies and we're
just trying to we're just kind of
discussing we went into that thinking
we're discussing really minor language
details as opposed to what came out but
then at that point we're like well wait
a minute
so the whole thing really
i can understand why that's a concern
and the testimony about the inconsistent
penalties
i i don't have my book open to it but
you accidentally record someone
it's a class a misdemeanor if
someone's
appearing in your in your window
well it makes me so happy that you know
that well
it warms the cockles of my eyes
chuckles when she says it too
well i'm just saying if it were to
happen the person peering in the window
because the person may not
own or possess anything any device that
can can do that i'm just my point i'm
making is
that the penalty for that could be it
says misdemeanor which mean it could be
a class b misdemeanor so it's actually a
less penalty to spy on someone who's
engaging in an intimate act
or just looking in the window you know a
bedroom of minor children there's no
distinction between minors and adults
literally you can be doing that
and face a lesser penalty just now i can
sit on my phone and by accidentally turn
on the recording
device and i'm committing a a greater
offense
i'm not hearing that's happening in how
these are enforced but you see the
inconsistencies there
and to fix those without making other
seeing
oh we need someone to make the motion
excuse me if ought to pass as amended
represent espio
ought to pass as amended uh make the
motion up uh to move out to pass as
amended
and as seconded by representative
pantologis
uh any further discussion
representing true
um
this the with the as amended this bill
could change all sorts of uh
bills for uh committees uh study
committees coming out of the senate if
the senate is going to jump on board
this which i'm not sure they will
i'm still looking at a
study committee
in the second year of the session
and i don't see how much value that's
going to uh going to create
i did hear testimony that there's uh
there's just so many other bills some of
the other rsas that are affected by
changes to 644.9 that we need to have a
for that to hold
any time you submit a bill you would
need to have a study committee first
because
time you amend anything it affects other
rsas
i don't see the value in a
study committee
coming out
with their recommendations sometime in
november to uh
although i do i do a smile at the
amendment
i
the points well taken i just know with
with this particular area of law
we want to be
very certain that we don't
do what we almost did in the committee
conference which was again not the
and i agree that there is a short window
of time for that report to be put
together and
we'll uh
hopefully they're able to
work that out within the time frame that
they have
represented pantologists
a little
ins
well a little knowledge someone that's
been here a while we've always done this
in order to get
a law that
could be put in in the session to come
in session
so it would be clear that what they were
doing if it was a study committee and
this law has been
a number of times been questioned over
what it's what it's for and what's not
for and how it's done
so i think the study committee would be
i did want to say that i i understand
the reservations about having a study
committee in the second year
um
but i think you know one of the things
we have to keep in mind with things like
study committees is basically one of the
things we signed up for and and i think
one of the things all of us have seen on
this committee
are bills that come through
that
really haven't been properly vetted
where a little bit more input a little
bit more time
from other legislators could have
resulted in much better legislation
and in the case of um
of the bill that the chair was talking
about
um that's a bill it's actually passed
through our committee a couple times
and you know we found out later on that
it's it's had problems so i think we
need to be selective but this is a good
example of one where we should we should
pick it
representative speedy i realized i
didn't really speak on my motion but um
i i just wanted to say i think that this
is as my colleague from portsmouth also
said this is worth studying i think it's
getting the right you know getting the
right clarification and um deciphering
why you know why one thing raises the
level of a felony while the other
only is a misdemeanor is important so
you know and i think if we can sort that
out in a committee that'd be great i
think the amendment you know
uh clarifies that the senate will take
the lead on it but um
yeah i think like
that's why i made the motion out of pass
see seeing no
hands raised at this time
will now move the question
if you in support of the motion of
octopass as amended please say yay
if you are opposed please say nay the
clerk will now call the roll
vice chairman roy
yes representative welch
yes
representative burt
no
representative rhodes yes
yes
clerk votes yes representative testament
no
representative true
representative pratt
yes
yay
representative harry dathright yes
representative panelakis
representative o'hearn
representative bordnay yes
representative muse yes
representative newman
yes representative schultz
yes
representative connolly
representative bradley
yes
representative espitia yes chairman
abbas
the chair votes yes
anyone
at this time we will now close the
senate bill
293.
the committee will be in recess to 1 45
pm
good afternoon everyone
at this time we will now open the public
hearing on senate bill 294 relative to
the release
of a dependent of a defendant
the committee now calls grant bossie for
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee i am grant bosse from the
new hampshire senate introducing senate
bill 294 on behalf of the prime sponsor
senator jeb bradley who is currently
stuck in an airport like he's in a tom
hanks movie
he thanks you for your understanding and
courtesy
back in 2018 the legislature came
together behind the principle that
criminal defendants who do not pose a
danger to society should not be held in
jail
solely because they could not afford
even a small amount of cash bail the
senate remains committed to that
principle
during that debate we heard repeatedly
that bail reform was targeted to
non-violent offenders and that people
accused of offenses such as murder rape
domestic assault would not be released
without bail if they posed a danger to
the public
we've seen bail reforms abused across
the country with violent offenders
walking out on one charge just to commit
another violent crime
here in new hampshire we've seen
defendants released back into the
community because bail commissioners
felt they had no choice
to keep someone who could pose a danger
to the community behind bars pending
trial those decisions are best left to a
judge
that's what sb 294 does it states that
for defendants charged with a limited
set of offenses
there would be a rebuttable presumption
that this person would be a danger to
the community they would still have the
opportunity to receive a reasonable bail
by going in front of a judge guaranteed
within 72 hours
sb 294 would also address people who
repeatedly miss their court appearances
if you miss three
three court appearances
in a three-year period you will be held
in pre-trial detention
bail should not be denied to people
because of their income but neither
should it be granted to people who have
proven that they cannot be trusted to
show up in court
sb 294 received a strong bipartisan vote
of 20 to 4 in the senate and we would
ask for your consideration and support
if you have questions for senator
bradley i will pass them along and make
sure you get an answer i'd also
recommend you speak to the other people
testifying on the bill representatives
from our local police departments are
here today to share with you some of the
stories that led senator bradley to
introduce this important legislation
thank you for your testimony
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee for holding this hearing today
for the record my name is ross connolly
i'm the deputy state director for
americans for prosperity new hampshire
and i'm here today to voice our
opposition to sb 294.
this bill and legislation should be very
familiar to this committee as uh it's
it's
very similar
to a bill this committee considered uh
earlier this year sb2 sb 92
uh and and the this legislation in our
view has a lot of the same
uh issues that that bill had uh this
bill will unnecessarily limit judicial
discretion discretion and increase jail
populations
and uh this bill is
it's a little more targeted than than
the house bill that this committee
considered a couple months ago uh
however uh it it still has uh some of
the issues that sb92 had including uh
having including misdemeanors in the
list of crimes for for those that shall
be held
under this proposal
we will be holding those accused of
misdemeanors
in jail uh for up to a week it's a
72-hour window but that does not include
weekends and holidays
and they will be held pre-trial
there are ways to strike a balance uh
with with public safety but this this
bill is taking machete when a scalpel
would be much more appropriate
uh furthermore sb 294 puts the burden of
proof on the defendant uh and not the
state uh similar to sb 92 this bill has
what's called the rebuttable presumption
uh
which
we believe our justice system was
founded on on the principle of innocent
until proven guilty and
this legislation puts that burden of
proof onto the defendant to prove that
they are not a danger to the public
that burden should always be on the
government
not the individual since it's the
government accusing the individual of
breaking the law
lastly this bill rolls back uh the state
policy that an individual should not uh
be held pre-trial simply because they
cannot afford bail
uh in contrast to a bill this body has
already passed sb 294
seeks uh seeks chain to change pre-trial
detention for first offenses not second
offenses
uh the these accused have not been again
they have not been convicted of any
crime uh they this is pre-trial
detention and as the current law uh is
written
uh those that are a danger to the public
or themselves shall be held pre-trial
they shall not get a pr bail
these protections already exist and the
legislature can clarify them further in
statute
especially in our view when it comes to
felonious violent crimes in particular
but this this bill uh the six-page bill
goes way too far in the other direction
but once again we would be happy to work
with the committee to find a solution uh
to address this in a very targeted way
instead of in a broad manner on a on a
six-page bill that has a large fiscal
impact so uh for those these reasons we
urge the committee to move this bill in
expedient to legislate and i'd be happy
representative espidia
uh thank you for uh thank you chair and
thank you for the question um so
what happens when folks who you know are
held pre-trial and then and like and
then end up being
uh ruled innocent what have like what
happens to them and do they you know if
they especially if they stay you know a
few days in jail
uh thank you for the question
representative
uh
they're released first of all but
there's a lot of collateral consequences
you could lose your job you could have
uh parental issues
there's a lot of consequences to holding
somebody in pretrial detention
beyond just the principle that that
these are innocent people accused of a
crime that has not been proven
uh that that we're detaining and that
should be in our mind done in a very
targeted way towards people who are a
direct threat to to a community or
themselves
representative pandelacas
thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my question
could you give me some examples of
people you think should be held other
than the ones that are listed
uh thank you for the question
representative i i i in terms of
examples again we we've proposed a list
of felonious violent crimes uh these are
serious crimes
and we believe that that was the intent
of the original bail reform law was was
uh that those people shall shall be held
pre-trial um there there's been some
anecdotes of of individuals being
released in certain areas uh that should
not be happening in our mind uh so again
having a more targeted uh approach to
this instead of including things like
domestic violence stalking that that are
class a misdemeanors uh having that be
felony level crimes we think would be
much more appropriate follow-up
representative pandelacas you're
recognized for a follow-up uh you
mentioned domestic violence crimes
don't you think that they should be held
because of
the tensions that
has arisen over that such as a husband
and wife in a fight or something don't
you think they should be held
uh thank you for the question
representative uh
there are varying degrees of domestic
violence there's a
felony level there's but this includes
class a misdemeanors which could be a
minor dispute uh again we we don't think
it's appropriate to automatically hold
those people without any discretion over
the the the
degree of crime or the the degree of
what they're being accused of
for up to a week in jail and potentially
losing
uh employment and and losi and creating
more consequences in the community that
doesn't actually address the issue that
that may be at hand
representative muse
yes thank you for taking my question
um
one of the things i'm curious about is
uh you you've kind of outlined some of
the the problems in the bill um and uh
something i'd like to know is are there
specific fixes uh that we could make to
the bill in front of us that would make
it uh acceptable to you and that would
address your uh your objections
thank you for the question
representative
yes i i believe so i
we we have come up with language uh that
that uh
we think would would address the issue
again there's an outstanding bill in the
senate there's there's uh this bill in
front of us today uh we don't believe
that it's a it's necessary to to pass
two pieces of legislation um you know
fixing one of one of those bills uh we
would be amen happy happy to work with
the committee on uh is finding a path
forward but to answer your question yes
we we do have a proposal a proposed
amendment that that would better address
representative muse you recognize for a
follow-up
not not to put you on the spot but i'm
putting you on the spot
[Laughter]
are there what are some of the specific
things that you would recommend
that need to be changed in this bill
uh thank you again for the question
representative and i don't mind being on
the spot
um
really
in terms of the length of the bill it's
a six-page bill um our biggest issues
are rebuttable presumptions uh you
should not have to prove your innoce
that you are not a danger to the public
that that should be on the government to
have to prove that uh the list of crimes
including misdemeanors
and i'm sure some some of the
attorneys that may be more familiar with
this issue uh
behind me uh maybe i'll give you more
detail but those are our top line sort
of issues with the bill that uh just the
br the broadness and scope and then some
of those issues of of uh you know
flipping due process on its head in our
mind
thank you mr chair and thank you for
in this bill one of the things that i am
really concerned about
is the change of the word may
and i'm looking for you to clarify if my
interpretation is correct
if you look at
why a person should be held in
preventive detention
it says the court and it has changed the
meaning of court
to judges and bail commissioners
so it says the court may order
preventive detention without bail
or an or an alternative
um
so the court has that decision and they
have some discretion and then when
assuring the court appearance of a
person
it says the court may
require
may require
preventive
detention
unless the court determines the
preponderance of evidence that such a
release will not reasonably meet the
requirements
so
in the law itself right now it says may
and then when you go down to
where it says
about
that
the
person shall be detained in pre-trial
detention
that word has now been used in in my
opinion that
gets rid of the discretion that the
court and the bail commissioners have in
those two cases
would that be a correct assumption
uh thank you for the question
representative yes i i would agree
shifting it from may to xiao removes a
lot of discretion uh you know not all
cases are alike
and and taking away that discretion
uh we believe puts ev puts everybody in
a one size fits all box
that
there should be much more attention to
the details of the case
and thank you for your testimony the
chairman choir with the question
if you look at roman numeral 3 b2 which
is page 2 lines 20-25
is there any
provision in that particular section
that you
uh
sorry what were the lines again
that's the section regarding
a person who's on pre-trial release
already someone who already has bail who
frequently would fail to appear
at
subsequent court hearings
uh thank you for the question mr
chairman uh
again similar to to our
issues with with uh hb 1476
uh it it doesn't give discretion to the
level of crime uh and we we would again
like to see this much more targeted to
actually address the issues that
everyone's concerned about which is the
release of of violent criminals that
that may reoffend uh or violent accuse
that may reoffend while while they're
out
we think it's appropriate to protect the
the public from
uh potential harm and and uh having that
be targeted directly towards those
uh that are there
uh most at risk to the community
thank you for taking my question if i
can just ask a follow-up so i guess my
concern is
is if there's what would the consequence
then be if they can't revoke your bail
for frequently missing hearings
that have been scheduled
how exactly do you hold someone
accountable for who would
miss it would have to be
three hearings
at three twice in the same case or three
times if it's more than one case in a
three year period how do you hold
someone accountable in those
circumstances
if you can't revoke their bail
thank you for the question
representative i i
our our
view on on uh people who are who are
missing hearings the the the most
frequent reason why individuals might
miss
a hearing is
transportation issues child care issues
employment issues
we don't think that that's a direct sign
that this person might be a threat to
the public
the the the judge the court system has a
lot of leeway in how to address uh
those on a case-by-case basis and we
think that's appropriate and should
representative bert
thank you mr chairman thank you for uh
from what i'm hearing that this is a
isn't there current laws
that they could apply
to keep somebody in jail but they're
elected not to follow those laws uh
thank you for the question
it it
it's on a case-by-case basis i i i
there there have been instances from
what i've seen of individuals who may
have been
uh released that shouldn't have been but
again those are
it's largely anecdotal uh it's targeted
in certain locations by and large we
believe that the 2018 uh reforms are
working we've seen a red it may not be a
causative variable but it's one variable
that that uh
crime has has reduced in the state since
so
on uh
i i i don't i can't answer your question
directly but but we believe that uh
that
the law clearly states that individuals
who are uh who could be a threat to
themselves or their community
shall be held and if that's not being
followed the issue isn't with the law
it's with who who may be implementing it
thank you
representative schultz
thank you mr chair um thank you for
taking my question
um on page two the lines um
one through three you mentioned this
excluding saturdays sundays and holidays
the 72-hour piece
and with the inclusion in this bill of
bail commissioners who i believe are on
call
at any point
do you have any thoughts about that
being
long enough
too long
uh whether these
saturdays sundays and holidays ought to
be excluded at all
uh thank you for the question
representative we we believe the the the
length of time is is uh quite burdensome
uh the the issue of weekends holidays
that's just how the court currently
operates they don't operate on those
those days uh i can't really comment on
whether we should start to to do that i
think that that could be a question for
for somebody from the court system uh
but but
we don't have much oppositio of a
position on that besides the fact that
these individuals who have not been
convicted of a crime are are being held
uh for for an extended period of time
that can really affect uh themselves and
representative true
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question and i think you just
you just hit upon it uh
i'm looking on page two line one uh the
accused uh shall
be detained for
what could be five six or seven days
which
for me is problematic that's a long time
to hold an accused person do you have
less burdensome
less than five or six days to be held
uh thank you for the question
representative
again our our our view is is to make
this entire piece of legislation simpler
and more targeted
uh and and part of that
would be uh the the length of detention
um and and uh the crimes that that are
representative muse
yes thank you thank you for taking my my
question again
um i know that one of uh afp superpowers
is uh
influencing legislation at the state
level
one of the things that i'm curious about
uh
the fact that new hampshire was not the
only state to implement bail reform in
the 2018-2019
uh time frame
are there other states that have had
similar issues come up
and
have any states address those in a way
that
is acceptable to you
and
um
that
that does
in ways that don't raise the same
concerns that sb 294 raise
uh thank you for the question
representative i i don't uh really have
a great answer of of the differences
there's been a lot of states that have
implemented changes to pre-trial uh over
the past few years they vary greatly uh
depending on on the location um you know
in in many instances there's been a lot
of stories in a location of of people
being
constantly released i i'm not sure what
the direct cause of that can be there's
there's a lot of different variables
but specifically in new hampshire we
haven't had a massive problem
of people
uh you know especially people accused of
violent crimes being released but in
those cases where that is happening we
do not view that as being appropriate
and
again
we are perfectly fine with codifying uh
that in into statute to be very very
clear that these people should should
not be uh released uh but it should not
be broad and it should not include
things that you will not uh serve jail
time or prison time for
if convicted
like misdemeanors
if the chairman inquires of a question
and
i'm referring to page 2 lines 34-37
and it goes on to page three
lines one through
seven
similar questions i asked
earlier
that that policy has to do with someone
who's been released
on bail they have conditions of the bail
they've been arrested for either drunk
driving a class a misdemeanor or a
felony
and then now i've been arrested a third
time
while out on bail
for again basically excluding violations
and class b misdemeanors with the
exception of drunk driving
is there
is there any alternative language you
would suggest
to that par that section
as oppo
uh thank you for the question question
mr chairman uh
we can certainly provide suggestions uh
on language uh if the the committee so
chooses i'll point out when it comes to
secondary third offenses uh this body
did pass a a a a bill that addresses
those uh those concerns uh we were
opposed to that as well for for the
broadness uh
of of the crimes that were included it
was pretty across the board uh but we do
have a language that that could improve
that of being much more targeted and
focused on on on the crimes that uh
everyone is concerned about
and if i just ask a follow-up again my
concern is if if someone were to
continuously get arrested while out on
bail or
two three times now
if there's if there's no consequence for
violating the conditions of your bail
i guess my question is what is the
purpose of having conditions of the of
your bail in the first place
again we we just don't want to see it
across the board very broad uh but in a
more targeted way if if somebody is out
on bail and they're constantly being
rearrested that is an issue and we had
provided some language to the committee
on uh
hb 1476 that specifically dealt with uh
you know some of the trespass issues
some of the
uh violent crime issues
but uh you know to keep in mind is
somebody that might be out on on uh on
bail gets arrested for uh cannabis
possession that's a class a misdemeanor
and and you you could be requiring them
to be detained
um for
again upwards of a week um
for for a crime that's uh in a lot of
people's mind not not a very serious
offense
uh and certainly not a threat to the
community so those are the sort of
situations that we we just don't think
that
having uh
no discretion over the level of offense
uh is is the best way to go we we think
respecting due process and having that
discretion
maybe you can clarify a little bit of
maybe my misunderstanding of what
rebuttal is
um so it says
this it says there is a rebut a
rebuttable
assumption
there shall be a rebuttable and this is
line 23 24. there shall be a rebuttable
presumption that release will not
reasonably assure appearance
in
the of the person as required
so that's the face that kind of puts the
the emphasis on the on the person that
has been arrested as opposed to being
innocent until proven guilty
but then and that's where the law used
to end
that was the end of the law and it went
back and said the court which means bail
commissions and judges
when they took if they found that there
was evidence that
that the person should be held either
because of dangerousness or not
appearing
um they would be able to do that but
then by ending that sentence with the
words
and the person shall be detained in
pre-bio
to me that means that
the judge and the bail commissioners no
longer have the opportunity to to review
the
what's going on what kind of evidence
there is to keep the person in in
custody which certainly i would presume
is the number of times that they have
failed to show up
so the shell cancels it out and takes
away the rebut ability if there is such
a word am i incorrect in that kind of
assumption
uh thank you for the question
i i would probably defer to somebody
behind me uh that is more familiar with
this but really rebuttable uh
you know presumption
it flips the the burden on the defendant
and that is not how our justice system
is supposed to work
it is it should be upon the government
the justice system to prove
that that an individual is guilty of a
crime or is a danger to the public in
this case
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
the witness for his testimony thank you
very much
and for the members of the committee
there is um i have to thank
i think brad our committee assistant for
putting this together together
there is a side-by-side analysis of
what the bill is before us right now
senate bill 294
and
what was senate bill 290
senate bill 92 has amended its 2-1 the
you don't have the side-by-side
mr chairman representatives
is this bill
i don't want to say representative
bradley
i i'll let me just clarify what so
senate we had a bill
last year senate bill 92
and it passed in this committee with an
amendment now it was ultimately tabled
so it was not
voted on it you know at least on its
merits
the side-by-side i was referring to now
this bill by the way senate bill 294 is
very similar to the
the original draft of senate bill 92
that passed in the senate last year
the side by side that
the committee assistant put together for
us
is the amended version that passed in
the committee last year as opposed to
what is
290 senate bill 294 as introduced
and there are there are some
significant differences just
i'm just trying to make sure everyone
representative bourne
thank you mr chair uh uh this analysis
is interesting but uh where's the
side-by-side analysis of
1476. since it's a bill that we've uh
passed relatively recently
and i think the committee
was more comfortable with than either
these two
versions
well i there is i'm sure there's there's
room to put another additional
side-by-side or a third
third version i think with hp 1476
that really had a narrow application
that'd do it with someone who was
already released on bail
and they were to get arrested all that
did
for mo for the most part was
he would bring you before a judge for
your bail hearing as opposed to a bail
commissioner
if you look at the third paragraph i'm
sorry page two at the bottom
line's 34 37
on the page three
lines one through seven that's
although it looks
similar to what 1476 would have done
it's actually very different because
in that case
that's what's happening when you're now
in in the court and deciding whether to
revoke your bail and hold you
in pre-trial detention what that's doing
is saying you continuously violate the
conditions of your release
and therefore
uh it's that's when the court will make
that decision this is what 1476 did
we're just holding you we're not going
to release you let you go before bail
commissioner you're going before a judge
that's my understanding that's that's
really kind of a cliff notes version but
i can have
i can ask brad to greenland to put them
together
and make a
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee uh for the opportunity to
testify today my name is frank knack i'm
the policy director with the aclu of new
hampshire we are here in strong
so i don't want to read my
the documents i sent out verbatim so
i'll just try and summarize them quickly
i think the first point we want to make
is that we should be really here focused
on how we can make our community safer
and if our goal here is to make our
community safer then this is the
absolute worst thing that we could do
so just more recently between when this
when 1476 was heard in this committee
and today another report came out funded
by arnold ventures which is a well-known
national organization working on
criminal justice reform and state state
level
and they uh the study they funded looked
at 1.5 million people booked into
kentucky jails between 2009 and 2018
pre-trial
pre-trial um and looked at
the out the outcome of that and this was
a study that was following up on
research they'd done a few years back
and so a few years back their findings
found that after three days of pre-trial
incarceration the net public safety
benefit went away and actually it was
the person was more likely to commit a
new crime after being held for three
days or more
their more recent research which looked
at 1.5 million people actually realized
that their earlier estimates were
incorrect and that any time over 24
hours
actually had a net public safety harm
and they found that you know that
jailing people pre-trial in the majority
of cases is absolutely the worst thing
that we could do and that we should
actually instead be focusing on
community-based solutions treatment
substance use etc to actually address
the underlying causes of what are
leading people into the jail most the
vast majority of times and they also
went out of the way to note that this
was an outlier research that this was
consistent with decades of research on
carceral approaches
to to offenses like this
and so again if we're focused on public
safety this bill is a really is a
solution that we should there is a
is a
is a direction that we should not be
going in
and again i think it's really important
important to note
existing law allows judges and bail
commissioners the power to hold anyone
pre-trial if they determine them to be a
danger
or a flight risk and if you'll know in
the packet i sent i just handed out and
i emailed the committee this morning i
noted the multiple parts in current law
that already allow
the courts to hold people pre-trial
including if they commit a new crime
there's also a section that hasn't been
discussed where
law enforcement where the state can
actually appeal a decision by the court
in terms of releasing someone so if they
think the court got it wrong there's a
provision in existing law where they can
they can challenge that and quote should
be
determined promptly by the courts
and so again we already have mechanisms
in place what this does in concurrent
laws ensures that is individualized
determinations not blanket solutions
that will nest and they needlessly
incarcerate potentially thousands of
people annually
and again it's also important to note
um that you know we've heard fear
tactics from these proponents of this
legislation that you know quote unquote
our you know our communities are less
safe and so we actually unfortunately
there was an article in the concord
monitor this morning that noted that you
know there was an attempt by um by the
state to do an assessment of the 2018
reforms and the data that they needed to
do that wasn't actually collected and so
from our perspective if we're talking
about needlessly incarcerating a bill
that can incarcerate thousands of people
we should actually look at the data
first to see if there is in fact a
problem rather than just a few anecdotal
stories that we're hearing that are not
that are not being provided with any
actual
data to show that there's a problem
and if you actually look at crime stats
since bail reform went into effect and
again i noted
in the packet i handed out
the crime statistics statewide for both
group a and group b for both arrests and
for new crimes they're down
substantially since bail reform went to
effects of statewide group a crimes
which are the vast majority of offenses
down 14.3 percent arrest down 22.6
percent and i also noted the stats from
the two police departments where the
chiefs have testified before you all
about the need
um to roll back bail reform and
needlessly incarcerate thousands of
people
and finally i want to i want to talk
about a few aspects of this specific
bill so again this is a very broad bill
compared to the bill you all heard
earlier this year as chairman abbas
noted it's more similar to the sb 92
which this
this body tabled a few months back
but in terms of failure to appear
as my colleague from afp noted you know
the current law gives judicial
discretion to incar to hold people
pre-trial if they fail to appear for a
certain number of times but again people
are not failing to appear because
they're trying to skip their court date
the vast majority of times people are
failing to appear
because of child care because of
uh you know
transportation issues things that are
outside the control and if we're really
concerned with addressing the fta issue
there are data-driven solutions to doing
that that other states have been doing
including text messaging text alerts
that have been shown to actually reduce
fta rates and not not needlessly
incarcerate individuals
and again
on the re-arrest issue
this bill compared to
sb1476 which you all heard a few weeks
back
this bill includes all
any if you're arrested for any offense
and then rearrested for any offense
including class b misdemeanors you are
mandatorily held this bill takes away
judicial discretion so again if we're
concerned about from a public safety
perspective this is the wrong solution
for new hampshire
and we urge that this committee oppose
representative pandelagas
thank you mr chairman
you just gave off some statistics about
crime being done down
did we not just go through two years of
staying home
would we not have
crime gone down because of that
so the data i showed you shows 2018 2019
so even in those two years which are pre
the first year bail form and pre-coveted
crime was down even in those two years
so and i'm not saying that bail reform
is the reason that crime is down but
what i'm saying is that the notion that
somehow bail form is making our
communities less safe is not supported
by any data but i do agree that you know
crime rates are skewed potentially
because of covid so we also included uh
2018 2019 which is pre-covered
follow-up
uh representative and the re-arrest
that's being done
um how do i explain to my constituent
that the gentleman next door broke up
the apartment broke out the windows they
arrested him
he comes home two hours later
it happens again
they asked me
why their police department has to put
up with this man why he isn't held for a
rest can you explain to me why we
shouldn't be doing that
so under existing law the judge the
court has the ability to hold that
person pre-trial and under existing law
the government has the ability to
challenge the court's decision if they
release them and so
we think it's best that the we give the
courts you know uh the authority to make
very serious decisions on all kinds of
matters
all the time and there's this is no
difference so we have judicial
discretion courts can make that
determination if the state doesn't like
that determination they have in a
mechanism under existing law to appeal
that and i think it's also important to
really recognize that for the vast
majority of these individuals
we're talking about people with
underlying substance use underlying
mental health
under other you know unhoused situations
those are the issues that we should
really be focused on and if you look at
the research from arnold ventures that's
what it really talks about that we
should be focused on are the you know
the drivers of what's making our
communities less safe and not in
recognizing that putting people in jail
is the worst thing that we can do
thank you
representative muse
thank you for taking my question if the
existing law
in your opinion uh is enough and ensures
that dangerous people can be held
what in europe
why in your opinion are we running into
uh to issues issues like this if the law
itself isn't a problem
so i i would actually really look at see
the fact that we actually don't have
data to show that there is a problem
we've heard a few anecdotal stories that
there are some issues um you know that
could be solved by better training of
bail commissioners better you know more
you know ensuring that we have more
judges more bail commissioners you know
there are other solutions but also you
know focusing on the front-end issues
you know ensuring that we have better
treatment programs you know there's
data-driven programs like cahoots out in
eugene oregon or a star program out in
denver colorado that are really focused
on addressing you know low-level
low-level issues in terms of mental
health and having proper responses to
mental health to reducing the need for
policing of mental health to reduce the
need for our jails for mental health so
there's lots of things that we could be
doing as a society if we were really
focused on public safety and this bill
is really
not focused on public safety
representative burt
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
you stated
there were some reasons uh child care
and transportation what are the other
reasons you know that some people just
you know can't show up to court and and
do you know what the court does with
so we looked at there was actually
a study paper by
the
public policy research
program i'm looking for the name at
dartmouth
that looked at the fta issue
with regard to new hampshire and
elsewhere and so what they found were
the main drivers were child care
transportation employment requirements
or they simply forgot
um and that they in that in that
research paper and i have it cited in in
my um fact sheet that i sent you all or
gave to you all um noted that there are
data-driven solutions in terms of text
messaging etc to um ensure that people
are more likely to show up and again i
think with with your question itself
you know judges have discretion if if
they think that there's a problem if
they think that the person is not
showing up because they're trying to
skip their court date
they can make that determination and
after the the the
number of uh the threshold is met they
can hold that person
and so this is just but right now we
have judicial discretion you know we're
ensuring that judges and not we don't
have a robotic response we have an
ability of judges to look at the
individual individual facts in that case
and determine whether or not you know
the person did in fact you know have a
car accident on the way to court and
couldn't make it or their kid got sick
and they couldn't make it to court or
you know their school you know i'm a
parent you know if school gets canceled
my day gets thrown completely
you know if there's snow on the ground
and schools canceled you know i have to
rearrange my schedule for the day you
know i'm lucky i have a job where i can
be flexible and do that but a lot of
people don't
um and so i think it's important that we
allow judges to look at those factors um
we don't have a uniform you know judges
or individuals we don't have a uniform
way of judges don't have a uniform you
know
code for you know this is valid this is
not but we do give them discretion in
lots of ways and
follow up mr chairman representative
brad you recognize for a follow-up thank
you
also i heard with the other bill that's
similar to this that's being heard on
the other side of the granite wall
that the court showed up
about the cost of this
yeah that'd be on the question you know
the cost of this do you know what that
would be and what that would do with the
courts
so um the court testified on this bill
when it was over in the house so i'm not
sure i believe
mr head is here from the courts i'm not
sure if he's testifying on this matter
or not but when they testified on the
house side i believe they said 1.9
million according to the um
to the hearing report
um and that i just also want to clarify
that that is just state court costs and
so we're talking about potentially
incarcerating thousands of people we
also have to think about the cost the
localities so join one person per day is
105 to 125 a day according to fiscal
notes and so times that by thousands per
day we're talking about a lot of money
that's going to hit everyone's locality
that is not included in the statewide
fiscal the what the court would tell you
if the chairman may inquire with a
question
you mentioned that there was some i
think the term is anecdotal stories
can you provide the information on what
what story or what was the fact pattern
or that story you were referring to
uh i'm just i'm referring to the stories
we've heard when law enforcement have
testified um in other hearings and then
in some media reports we've heard from a
few anecdotal stories that they've given
can you give some background on what the
you know can you put the background and
one of those stories around when you say
story i mean what what are you referring
to someone arrested let out what
happened that's what the law enforcement
have alleged and they have i've not seen
any data so i can't give specifics we've
just heard the anecdotal kind of you
know high-level stories
and again we've heard nothing that you
know from them that you know under
existing law that person couldn't have
been you know held so i think again this
gets back to a data problem and that we
need to be focused on collecting the
data to see if there is in fact a
problem and then we can have data-driven
solutions you know i think one of the
great things about
criminal justice reform over the last
you know decade and a half starting in
texas in about 2008 was we were actually
able to collect data and look at what is
and what is not working and then
construct
policy solutions that are
nearly territorial to those problems and
i think when you do things without data
that's how we got to mass incarceration
in the first place you know we had this
knee-jerk reaction to incarcerate people
for all types of offenses and that led
to us being the incarceration capital of
the world and so i think it's important
that we get back to the kind of
data-driven solutions that have been
effective at reducing incarceration
levels across the country
and ensure that all of our policies are
data-driven and not rhetoric driven
thank you if i can ask a follow-up
question in regards to
a person who fails to appear at a
hearing so let's begin page 2 lines
20-25
you gave an example of someone who got
will get in a car accident on the way to
the court hearing
i would think that my own opinion that
would be an excusable reason why someone
didn't make it to the court
but
if
wouldn't that person under
under the bill as proposed have a
rebuttable presumption to show why
they won't miss future hearings because
basically say well one of them i was in
the car accident the way to the
courthouse
wouldn't that
in your in your opinion would that
satisfy the rebuttable presumption or
not
so
under current law they have a runnable
presumption the way that this bill would
amend it would be actually taking away
that rebuttal presumption and saying the
the last line is and the person shall be
detained pre-trial
so this is actually taking away the
judicial discretion this amendment um so
under existing law you're absolutely
correct that
you know if they're not if they if they
don't show up for the the threshold
number of times there's their quote
there shall be a rebuttable presumption
that release would not reasonably assure
the appearance of the person as required
but as this bill is amending it it
includes this next sentence or this next
part of the sentence and the person
shall be detained pre-trial
so this bill
you're right under existing law there
was rebuttal presumption and we're okay
with that
this bill actually creates a sh takes
puts the shell on there and mandates
their incarceration
but wouldn't the rebuttable presumption
language still remain in the law even if
this bill were to pass
it remains in the
the text but the second sentence the
second part of that sentence says the
person shall be detained so i think it
would be pretty clear that they
would be detained it it has the shell in
there
thank you and so i mean it sounds like
there are people that we hear anecdotal
evidence about
that they're in and out in and out in
and out and it may be because they're
you know flipping off the justice
um
commit justice
but
wouldn't this with that shell in there
that that takes away the rebuttal i mean
maybe you would get rebuttal after 72
hours but that certainly isn't the
solution am i
does that make any sense to you
yeah i mean it's definitely a little
confusing i think the language
the way it would be interpreted is that
the shell in there is the controlling
and they would be held and i don't mean
to minimize these you know anecdotal
stories i mean these are you know
horrible things that are happening but
again having a targeted solution versus
this one-size-fits-all solution
we can't legislate i mean i think it's
it's it's it's um
not right to legislate based on anecdote
and so we we should really really focus
representative conley
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
kanek for taking the question so it's
different parts to this bill um
the the back half i think is addressed
largely in hp 1476 which just left this
chamber
and then there's the beginning part
which deals with folks who are charged
what is the position of the aclu around
holding people charged with serious
crimes where there's an a true victim
and getting him before a judge and and
making a decision on bail is that
something that
um that your group would support
so i believe this has
a rebuttable presumption that they're a
danger to the public um which we think
again under existing law anyone can be
held pre-trial
and so we think that's appropriate that
the judge or the the bail commissioner
can look at the facts in that case and
determine whether or not the person is a
danger or a flight risk to the community
and i think it's also important to
remember that these are people who are
charged and so when the prosecutor gets
the case filed as you all know very
often happens in new hampshire charges
can be reduced and so just because
someone is charged with the defense
doesn't mean it's actually what's going
to happen once the prosecutor gets the
case file
and so again
having this mandatory scheme of just
because you're charged with an offense
means that there's a rebuttable
presumption that you're a danger we
think is problematic we think existing
law
has many opportunities to ensure that
people who are a danger it gives
individualized determination to see if
they are a danger and if they are they
can be held and that's appropriate
but the rebuttable presumption i think
is is problematic
representative connolly recognized for a
follow-up thank you mr chairman this is
actually a different topic altogether
but i'm curious about that the number
that's been used by opponents that
thousands of folks would be swept up i
mean how many i mean i live in dover
which is one of the largest cities in
the state we have weeks where there's
just a handful of people arrested so
where's that number coming from
what time frame are we talking about and
can you can you clarify that a little
bit um i believe and i don't want to
speak i believe that came from testimony
from the courts in terms of the number
of people who this could impact on an
the chair may inquire of a question and
thank you again for taking my question
you heard me mention before that there
was a previous senate bill 92 that had
an amendment to it
and although that had the same 13
offenses listed
are you familiar with that amendment i
don't want to ask about
that policy because it did rewrite that
whole majority of that section yeah i
have sp i think i have the amended sp 92
so rather than have the rebuttable
presumption
just to sum up that policy it would
reduce the time to 24 36 hours as
opposed to 72
and it essentially would just hold the
person who was charged with one of those
13 offenses
not put them bring them before bail
commissioner bring them before a judge
in that case if the state not the
the state would have to prove
by clearing convincing evidence that
person posed a danger to themselves
or to the public
and that's in that scenario
that person then could be held
in regard to that policy
would would you have any objection to
that as written and if so would there be
any
uh changes you would make to that policy
oh definitely i mean i'm so looking at
this right now
it is definitely less problematic than
the proposal in the current s294 sb294
but again i think as i just mentioned to
representative conley i think our
concerns are that these are these are
the charges that i mean you're so you're
automatically detaining someone based on
a charge that the prosecutor when they
get the case file made to decide was way
way too much and so again under existing
law
not even not only for these 13 offenses
but for any offense incl you know any
offense if the person is determined to
be a danger they can be held and again
we've been shown no data to show that
that is a problem that that's
inappropriate and if if it's a question
of you know making sure that we have
more judges more bail commissioners
better educational bill commissioners
those are all things that we should
consider but again going back to the
data you know we are talking about going
down a road that you know research paper
after research you know data-driven um
reports after data-driven reports have
shown is the worst option that we could
take as a society
and again we should be focused on on
community supports that are actually
going to address the underlying causes
of of crime
if i could just ask a follow-up
what i'm asking is as opposed to if a
person commits one of the 13 offenses
listed
rather than that person be
brought before any bail commissioner
if they were brought just before a judge
i mean this that policy alone is there
any objection to that policy
it doesn't mean they're going to be held
you know pending in pre-trial detention
they just held pending their arraignment
which is would be within 24 to 36 hours
obviously excluding the
weekends and holiday issues so we don't
necessarily have a concern if they're
brought you know as long as they're
brought promptly but i think our concern
is that 24 to 36 hours when you add in
weekends you add in holidays that is
multiple days that people would be away
from their families away from their jobs
away from their daily responsibilities
and again this is just based off of a
charge
and so ensuring that those people can
get before someone immediately to
determine whether or not they are danger
we think is the best approach and that's
the approach that data
representative schultz thank you mr
chair
so um
at the beginning of your testimony you
mentioned that this bill
uh
you stated that this bill would
essentially be less safe
for our communities
so am i hearing you correctly that a
social safety net through our judicial
system rather than those with the proper
training on
substance misuse
housing for all is a more expensive and
less
safe
system that is very expensive as well
like the wrong the wrong approach as a
society
to our um
social safety net
yeah i think if you actually if you look
at research on carson approaches to
public safety the research is pretty
clear that those were very limited
exceptions is the worst way we could go
as a society and again if you look at
social science it's fairly clear that if
you actually invest in housing supports
there's a correlation between access to
housing and reductions in crime rates
there's a correlation between living
wage access and reduction in crime
weights and so if we as a society are
really concerned about public safety we
should look at where the social science
shows us we should be investing and
prioritizing those those programs and
again or also with with mental health
supports you know the star program i
mentioned in denver cahoots out in
eugene
are our data-driven programs that
are making those communities safer and
saving lots of tax dollars at the same
time
thank you
if i may inquire with the question i
understand the point of maybe being
preemptive in dealing with housing and
mental health issues
that's not something that's gonna happen
overnight so
is there any reason why
you can't
why not do both
i think the reason we wouldn't want to
do both is if you look at the research
you know as the most recent one from
arnold ventures found jailing someone
for as little as 24 hours actually has a
public safety harm connected with it
that those people are more likely to
commit a future crime because they're
being pulled away from their community
and so if we have immediate dollars to
invest in something like this which is
going to cost millions of dollars we'd
be much better off investing those
dollars into community supports and
ensuring that people are getting the
representative espitia
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question would you believe
that there is a saying
um that is it's friday avoid the
bookings
i had not heard that but um it makes
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
the witness for his testimony
and thank you for taking all of our
questions i appreciate it thank you all
for your time
the committee now calls ophelia
bond
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee thank you for the
opportunity to testify today my name is
ophelia burnett i'm a manchester
resident and i am the healing justice
organizer intern with american friends
service committee
i am here today in opposition of
sb 294 so we all know the saying
innocent until proven guilty but with
this legislation sb 294 it really
changes that whole concept to guilty
until proven innocent
why
this legislation takes away granite
stater's opportunity to see a bail
commissioner this presents the
individual for making bail which then
mandate 72-hour period of incarceration
before seeing a judge
there will be a ripple effects from
which this brings terrible consequences
we all have jobs that our households
depend on with these individuals being
held up to 72 hours their jobs are now
at risk and this can lead to termination
we have been so dependent on our cell
phones for so long that while being held
these individuals
are unable to remember numbers to call
their jobs to let them know they will be
out for a couple days
even if they could remember a number
when first arriving at the doc you were
only able to make collect calls
i'm sure the workplace is not taking
collect calls from the jail and i'm sure
no one wants to even take
any collect calls from a jail
i'm sorry and i'm sure no one wants to
even make those kind of calls to their
employer so there goes their job
and then that leads to not being able to
pay bills rent etc now we have
individuals getting evicted and possibly
being homeless
then here we are
going adding to already growing homeless
epidemics here in the granite state and
we'll be back here on a different date
talking about another issue we have
going on and have to fix
so are we really trying to heal and
better our community or are we trying to
make things harder for people of our
community to elevate and crawl out of
failing systems
i know that as members of this committee
you are trying to make decisions for the
good of our communities and state as a
whole while sb 294 will not help us
this legislation expands the
criminalization of poverty current law
says that judges must consider an
individual's income and their ability to
pay when settling bail when setting bail
excuse me current law also creates
mechanisms so that individuals can be
detained if they're posed if they pose a
danger to their community
sb 294 partly undoes this important
reform and allows the incarceration of
individuals simply because they cannot
afford bill
new hampshire must ensure the people
that justice systems work for all of us
and not just according to our financial
status
this legislation also over incarcerates
individuals pretrial because it
determines who remains free
pre-trial by crime and not
individualized situations
sb 294 will incarcerate those who are
not dangerous those who are not at
flight risk those who will have charges
dismissed and those who would not who
would be found not guilty it makes me
think about a time almost two decades
ago when i was a teen and had a run in
with the law i was young hanging with
the wrong crowd wrong place wrong time
and i got inc i got arrested
i don't know what
bail reform bills were in place at the
time
but i know i did not see a bail a bail
commissioner
when i had my arraignment i was told i
had to post a 200 000 cash bail
cash bail i didn't kill anyone
i was fresh out of high school most
popular no priors i was so distraught my
mother was devastated so i'm held at
valley street jail for a month trying to
get my bail reduced i mean two hundred
thousand dollars cash who has that kind
of money laying around
my request to lower my bail was denied
so i waited at valley street for over 18
months i was 19 years old and i'm
literally fighting for my life
being young
not knowing the system my mom being
elderly and sickly at the time from the
agony of what was going on with me she
didn't have the funds to get that kind
of a lawyer i needed from my situation i
was told that if i went to trial and
lost i can do prison time
for seven and a half to 15 years but if
i took a plea after already serving
almost a year and a half i would only
have to serve another two and a half of
course being young scared and naive and
wanted to get out of that hell hole so
badly i took the plea
and with this legislation sb 294 will
put people and fair and scared
individuals to making the choice like i
did
about two weeks ago i sat in the senate
hearing on hp 1476
and two police officers stated that
people only talk and think about the
people who commit these crimes and never
the victims but with this legislation
like sb 294 you are making more victims
making more victims of this revolving
cycle in this justice system
i tell my story to say these kind of
proposals don't help situations or
better our community in my opinion they
cause more pain and harm
it took years of mental health
counseling medication and my strong
family and my friends acting as a
support system
to get
right here where i am sitting today to
tell my story
but not everyone has a support system or
the strong mindset i had which is why i
sit here as a voice for those who don't
have a chance or voice to sit up here
and say bills like sb 294 should be
opposed
let's find better solutions to our
problems like substance misuse treatment
programs
mental health facilities and getting to
the root why individuals are doing the
things they do
putting people behind walls and throwing
away the key is not the solution
representative schultz
thank you mr chair i just wanted to
thank you it takes a lot of courage to
come here and tell your story to benefit
others i hope you don't mind that that
was just
i could tell that that was an emotional
testimony for you so i just wanted to
recognize that thank you it wasn't a
thank you for taking my question do you
feel that you were wrongly charged and
did time for that
for doing nothing
yes i do think i was
representative marston
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
if it's not too presumptuous what was
the underlying charge for you
at the time
point of order
really i just wanted to make sure that
the witness knows she doesn't have to
answer that question just oh okay
when a point of order is raised
the first thing i need to do is
address the point point of order so
represent calling please state your
point of order
mr chairman i withdraw the point of
order
if you would draw the point of order the
representative would be
potentially be committed to
it's an issue of decorum i'm just
mr chairman
two years into this term
i just was attempting to to let the
witness know that there may be a
sensitive question that she didn't have
to answer
there was no other uh immediate tool
that came to mind so i said point of
order if that was wrong i really
apologize for that
i understand and just
to the witness if there is and this goes
to anyone uh here if questions asked by
a member to the witness and
the member of the public is not
comfortable answering the question it's
not like a courtroom where you must you
know i can't order you to answer the
question
so if and i would hope the members would
try to be respectful and ask questions
that i'm not saying that the
representative manchester was doing
anything intentional or not but just i
representative burt
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
again i come back to
i'm hearing
not a hundred percent but the majority
of this is a manchester problem that
they're having
how
could we fix this without passing laws
um
and thank you for that question uh
representative like
like i was saying in my testimony i
really feel like we
um as like i was saying i feel like we
should be really working on the roots of
the issues on why people are doing the
things that they're doing i don't feel
like
putting people in prison is what's going
to help
these issues i feel like you know people
are doing some things because of things
they've went through as a child
substance abuse issues and things like
that and i feel like if we take care of
those underlying issues we can stop a
lot of the crimes that are being taken
representative bert you recognize for a
follow-up question thank you mr chairman
and
i'm assuming you're out in the public
you know seeing this yes i am thank you
do you
know what the average
education is of people that are you know
sadly in this position that are are
doing this
i can't say that i do
um i know that i'm actually going to
school to be a lawyer myself so that i
can be aware of what's going on and be
more knowledgeable to things like that
but for everybody else i can't speak for
them all right thank you
thank you for your question
thank you for taking my question and and
sharing your experience um
would you say that the experience you
had is unique or have you heard of other
cases
similar to yours
um i think everybody's story is unique
um everybody has their own story to tell
every individual does
i feel like mike
i don't really want to get into it too
much i just feel like my case could have
definitely been
dealt with um
in a different manner
and i feel because of that
i'm not going to say unfortunate but
fortunately it made me the person i am
today it took a lot of things away from
me but i do feel like the justice system
kind of failed me and it took a lot of
things away from me but like i said it
made me who i am today and i'm a lot
stronger
but things could have been could have
representing muse you recognize for a
follow-up
would you agree that your case points
out that there is an other side to some
can you re
may rephrase the question yeah rephrase
that please yes would you would you
would you agree that um
that your case points out
that
there's a
a different aspect to some of the
anecdotes we hear a lot of the anecdotes
that we hear
are worst case scenarios from a victim
standpoint your
your case appears to be almost a worst
case scenario from the standpoint of
somebody who's accused of a crime
well
you know i feel like as far as like the
bail you know i didn't get a chance to
they gave me such a high bail for for
instance i couldn't even get out and and
fight on the outside and be with my
family i was snatched
from
my family immediately um they made it so
high that
i don't even know who unless you were
famous or rich can pay a 200 000 cash
bail so that traumatized me i thought
that i was going home once they told me
i was going to have a bail hearing i
thought they would at least lower it i
didn't kill anyone i never had any
priors like i said in my testimony so
once i went to my bail hearing and i
didn't get my bail lowered that was
another traumatizing situation for me
after already being snatched away from
my family so
it was very unfortunate so
yeah
thank you and thank you for taking my
questions
uh you say in your testimony that you
didn't see a
if you would respond as much as you
think you should respond
kind of
was it business hours was it after hours
that you were arrested was there a
reason why you didn't see a bail
commissioner just just what your
experience was like
of being arrested and not seeing a bail
hearing a commissioner and then
going to a bail hearing which i assume
was in front of a judge and if you don't
want to respond to that that's fine no
that's fine
representative i don't know like how
you know some of these bills are now
like when you come in uh when you get
arrested you can't see a bail
commissioner depending on your charge or
you have to wait a certain amount of
hours and things like that but i do
remember
when i got arrested i didn't see a bail
commissioner i know um like mostly in
all cases you go to your arraignment on
the next day which i did they
they made my bail at two hundred
thousand dollars cash and then usually a
month later they let you have your um
your bail hearing and that's when i went
and they said they were not lowering my
bail they were keeping at two hundred
i'm gonna thank the witness for her
testimony
the committee now calls jeff wood from
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee it's uh
i apologize my handwriting is poor
probably because i'm left-handed jeffrey
ward
i'm a senior assistant attorney general
and the chief of the criminal justice
bureau at the attorney general's office
i am here and have
previously worked with this committee
on senate bill 92 which i know was
referenced
but here really to provide uh what i'll
call some technical feedback with
respect to this bill
um
my office i think we are
again generally supportive of what the
um what the bill is attending to
accomplish and happy to
answer any broader questions but there
are a few
i think again technical issues that i
think are important um with respect to
this bill
if it is passed by by the committee and
by the house
um
and they speak to some of the work uh
that my office does in particular in the
criminal bureau we handle is as i think
many of the members of the committee are
aware
of the homicide cases statewide
or excuse me all the murder cases
statewide
and on if i'm looking at the right
version on page 2
excuse me page 1
line 25
that section in terms of listing the
enumerated crimes
uh that are addressed uh under the
72-hour initial hold uh again up to
72-hour initial hold i think that's
worth pointing out and i'm happy to
discuss that in more detail
but the
read the person who is charged with
homicide under rsa 630 colon 1.
rsa 630 colon 1 is not the crime of
homicide rsa 6 colon 30 rsa 630 colon 1
is the crime of capital murder
so if the bill is intended to cover all
homicide crimes it should simply say rsa
630.
in addition i think it's important for
the committee to be aware that the
there's currently again speaking
specific as to homicide crimes or crimes
that are punishable by up to life
imprisonment which can be some
subsequent offense crimes
uh there is already a bail provision
that deals with
those circumstances it's rsa 5971c
and what
rsa5971c
says is that those individuals that are
charged with crimes uh that are
punishable by up to life imprisonment
again something we often deal with with
murder cases that we handle those
individuals shall not be allowed bail so
long as the proof is evident and or the
presumption great and so there's a
there's a presumption there that those
folks aren't going to get bail at all
not that they'll be held for 72 hours
and then have a bail hearing um and not
that there's a rebuttable presumption
but that they will not get bail and
that's been the state of the law since
uh 1993 was when
rsa5971c was passed
so the last time this came around senate
bill 92 it was our recommendation that
the statute should read or that the bill
should read again on line 25
that except is provided for an rsa 5971c
a person who is charged with homicide
under rsa again
and and so on and so forth as the
language reads that would acknowledge
that for murder crimes first-degree
murder second-degree murder capital
murder there's a separate bail provision
that deals with those offenses um and
and what the standards are in terms of
holding people without bail who are
charged with those crimes and would also
make clear uh that this is intended to
apply to all homicide crimes
manslaughter negligent homicide as well
and those may be cases where someone
could be entitled to bail
under this statute
and i'm happy to provide
written language with respect to that to
the committee if that
as opposed to
expecting that you'd be able to follow
along necessarily with it
i will point out as well with respect to
the 72-hour provision in this bill
that there are
are already in place court rules
concerning the timing of an arraignment
if someone has been detained following
their arrest
new hampshire rule of criminal procedure
4 which deals with initial proceedings
in circuit court the new hampshire rule
of criminal procedure 10 which deals
with arraignment
in superior court
speaks to how long someone can be held
uh
and before they are brought uh before
the court for arraignment and it's it's
not that the timelines are different
it's just put differently and i might
recommend that this committee uh take a
look at that language and bring this
bill into compliance uh or make it
consistent with this the current
court rules both in circuit court and in
uh superior court with respect to uh the
timing of arraignment
um
beyond that uh
those issues um
that we spotted and wanted to make sure
got corrected i'm happy to take any
questions on on the bill in general or
those specific issues although i know
there are folks from the law enforcement
community here who will provide better
information than i'm able to with
respect to how this has impacted the
day-to-day operations of their
departments
thank you for your testimony and if the
chair may inquire with the question
in in respect to the
amendment 2 1
8 0 h that was
that applied to senate bill 92
did that address the concerns of making
making the
policy proposal consistent with the
court rules
it's as i recall and i apologize mr
chair i don't believe i still have that
particular amendment with me but as i
recall sorry what did you say the number
was it again
it was amendment number 21808
okay no that's a different one um but as
i recall again having worked
with you and senator bradley on this
last time around um i believe brought it
into compliance with those court rules
it was my recollection anyway without
having it in front of me my apologies
but the language from those court rules
taken before the superior court no later
than 24 hours after the arrest saturday
sundays and holidays accepted or no
later than 36 hours after arrest if
arrested between 8 am and 1 pm and the
person's attorney is unable to attend an
arraignment etc etc
um and so so long as that's
similar to the language you're talking
about and i and i think it i think it
was
then that would bring it into compliance
with the court rule
um and the courts regularly
the courts obviously are not open on
saturdays and sundays or on holidays but
if there are arrests over the weekend
that 24-hour rule brings folks in for
arraignments usually in the afternoon of
the first day after the arrest if
they're arrested too late in the day
they're not going to be arraigned until
the following day
representative burt
for coming today
i'm hearing rumors that
we're going to next year
come up with a magistrate system
and if that happened would senate bill
294 be needed
if we had a magistrate where they could
see
you know any time of the day
in weekends you know see these people to
so that's a rumor i hadn't heard um and
i and i i think i would
hesitate to answer that not knowing how
that system would work
um
you know there
and there are certain crimes and i think
what this makes makes clear and again
with what we deal with with homicide
crimes
those ha and there's another provision
rsa5974 that says
in in a murder case
if there is going to be bail said it can
only be set by a superior court justice
so depending on how that magistrate
system would work it it may or may not
deal with some of these issues but i
think part of
the issue here is not
necessarily how long these these people
are held because anyone who commits one
of these enumerated crimes they're only
held for up to 72 hours up to
uh and then they're allowed bail with a
with a rebuttable presumption so any of
these people charged with these crimes
can still get bail whether or not a
magistrate could see them on the weekend
um might not change whether or not they
were able to rebut that presumption or
whether or not they should be detained
which which is i understand the bill is
is the aim here all right thank you
representative tessman thank you
thank you for taking my question
along the same lines
uh i think this is discussed in one of
our hearings before
but
the issue seems to be
the
the lack of judges
or
couldn't we solve all of these problems
if we had enough judges on call 24 7
you know just to sign them
superior court judge
uh you know on a weekend you get the
calls you know if there's a call for
bail and we get rid of all these bail
commissioners
i think again what the what the
bill as i understand it is aimed at
addressing is
is whether or not
there should be a presumption that
certain people are are danger to the
public and therefore should be held
rather than than given bail and that
those are the folks charged with the
enumerated crimes in the section that i
was just referencing those i believe
someone has said 13 crimes
so
i don't view this issue as a judge
availability issue certainly there are
bail commissioners available but we're
talking about these these folks having a
bail hearing in front of a judge
um
and it doesn't strike me as that it's a
weekend issue
no i i
you misunderstood i'm saying we'll make
a
judge available 24 hours a day seven
days a week for even these kinds of
crimes and get rid of the bail
commissioners just have these kind of
without this legislation i presume your
question is would that cure the problem
and therefore not you wouldn't need this
legislation and my answer to that would
be based on my understanding of the goal
of the legislation it's to make clear
that certain crimes
because of the danger that they pose to
society because they're victim crimes
because of the harm caused that we want
there to be a presumption that these
people are going to be
potentially detained after a bail
hearing so
this
this carves out those crimes and so i
think regardless of when the bail
hearing occurred it still provides the
carve out and the statement by the
legislature that these are dangerous
crimes that
that there should be a rebuttable
representative newman
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um
do these 13 serious crimes that are
listed in the bill
have lesser included charges in them
that may be punishable only by a
misdemeanor with no jail time or maybe
even a violation or do you have that
knowledge
so there are uh you know i believe it's
been pointed out with respect to
stalking or domestic violence there are
misdemeanor variants of those crimes
and and i think that's what you're
asking is whether or not there are
misdemeanor variants of the crimes
and for so many of our crimes there are
lesser included offenses potentially
that's usually something that only comes
into play during the course of a jury
trial and the instructions given to a
jury as to what they can convict someone
of
the term lesser included
but certainly there are misdemeanor
variants of stalking and uh
and i think uh
there was a reference to um
domestic violence crimes
aggravated felonious sexual assault
felonious sexual assault there's also a
misdemeanor sexual assault but that's
not listed here so again what you're
dealing with is what the initial crime
charged is
at this point and certainly if someone
as i think someone pointed out if
someone was charged with felonious
sexual assault and a prosecutor chose to
only go forward on a charge of sexual
assault and that would change the bail
represent newman you recognize for
follow-up thank you
so if
so if there are those lesser included
crimes
and we've enumerated the ones that have
that are felonies or greater
would this bill be improved by listing
the lesser included crimes in there as
i i guess i don't see how that would how
that would improve the bill because you
have the enumerated crimes so including
crime other crimes to say they're
accepted i think every crime not listed
is accepted
um from this list
and so
i think you would i think it would end
up creating perhaps more confusion if
you listed only a few that were accepted
when based on this list every other
crime in the criminal code is accepted
representative muse
yes thank you for taking my question
um
as as a prosecutor
if you want a person who's accused of a
crime
held for dangerous dangerousness under
the current statute
is that an easy thing for you to do is
that a fairly simple court procedure
uh
it's hard to answer that as a generality
it's going to depend on the case
so you know to say that to have anybody
held is an easy thing i think would be
an oversimplification of of the process
um certainly not any number of factors
from the facts of the offense the
offense charged
that person's criminal history or lack
thereof um other other risks
flight risk connections to the community
or lack thereof
all those sorts of things are going to
come into play as to whether or not that
person is held whether or not it's easy
to get someone held i would not say it's
easy to get someone held in the general
sense
absent those crimes that we deal with
the murder crimes where it's automatic
in the first instance but that being
said that can still be challenged and we
have to have evidentiary hearings to
meet our burden to hold that individual
so it's certainly not an easy process um
and and to be frank it shouldn't be um
in order to take someone's liberty away
but there should be a recognition
that certain crimes uh pose such a
significant danger to the community uh
that that there's going to be a
presumption that those folks can be held
one that can be overcome but are
presumption
representative muse yes
so i i guess another way to to phrase my
question is
um there seems to be some disagreement
whether or not sb 294 is actually
necessary
given the fact that the current law
allows people to be held for
dangerousness
so
one of the things that i'm
mulling over in my own head is
what
are the advantages of the approach
outlined
in
sb 294 over the current law
uh where the x factor seems to be the
circumstances and the judge you know
that that the hearing would happen in
front of
it would seem like the circumstances and
the judge would continue to be variables
under sb
294 so
you know yeah you're correct in saying
that the the the facts of a particular
case and the judge are always going to
be uh going to be variables that are
you know out of the control at least of
of legislation you can't you can't
legislate this to every single case um
but what i again see is the point behind
this bill is to is to provide
those judges the prosecutors defense
attorneys with guidance under those
situations and the guidance is that
these limited crimes
um are are are ones where there should
be a presumption that they should be
detained
um as opposed to it just being a a
an open question with respect to
whatever crime is at issue is you're
providing a guide post
to those judges
under these circumstances you're saying
look at these 13 crimes cases that
involve these 13 crimes serious crimes
crimes of the victims
and uh and can that's that's correct
so
please correct me if i'm wrong my
question is if
so assuming that obviously
it's pretend it's not a leap year 365
days
exclude the weekends that's
doing some rough math here 104 days
52 weeks
if there were let's just say 20 legal
holidays i don't think there's that many
if you would subtract 124 from 365 i got
the number 241 days
the number i come up with you divide
that into the 2839 is less than 12 court
hearings a day throughout the entire
state
i'm just wondering would the with the
court system at this moment time be able
to handle the 12 additional hearings
throughout the entire state so thank you
for the question the the issue is
it would be great if crime were evenly
distributed time and and geographically
and unfortunately it's not
um so what what i looked at it is
one we have really
the the four again i'm focused on
circuit court the four circuit courts
that i have the heaviest criminal docket
is really where you're going to see the
focus of of these decisions
so
you've heard your manchester as being a
likely spot really what we're talking
about manchester nashua concord and
rochester as being the four circuit
courts that are most likely to be
impacted
and then i take from that you know a
total of
within not just those four courts i
admit but within primarily those four
courts i have to add 7.3 weeks of total
hearing time so those those the numbers
that we're talking about
we're obviously talking about them in in
different number forms you know number
of hearings versus hours of hearings or
minutes of hearings those numbers
convert into into hours and minutes
and then you look at it from the
perspective of
the and i'm not talking judges so much
i'm talking staff within these four
circuit courts
it is a remarkably complicated thing
that they do incredibly well on a daily
basis in circuit courts because people
are getting a
it's not like a civil case where you
know you file a complaint the other side
files an answer somebody has to do
something 30 days after that we're
talking about things we don't know about
that are happening so so
you know
the the
clerk's offices are receiving the
paperwork and they then have to get a
person the person who is the defendant
in front of a judge whether that's going
to be by a video or in person if it's
going to be a video it's got to be
coordinated with a county jail
what is interesting about
covet in the pandemic is we have taken
advantage of the technology and we're
holding more and more video arraignments
video hearings
and there are a limited number of slots
of video available in a particular jail
in a particular jail may have to
feed those slots to multiple different
circuit courts
so one circuit court may have nine to
ten the next circuit court may have 10
to 11. and there are you have to do
those in 5.8 minutes so there are
limited number of hearings you can hold
in that hour and that limited number of
people that can be presented so i have a
clerk who's trying to coordinate with it
with a county jail to put a defendant in
front of a video camera and a judge in
front of that
camera on the opposite end to make sure
we can have a bail hearing at the same
time
if that
jail does not have an available video
slot i probably in order to meet the
time consequences the clerk has to now
arrange with a sheriff or transport from
the jail to the courthouse
so again it's it's a
they are incredibly good at this because
it happens every day fairly seamlessly
um but it takes a great deal of effort
and manpower because all this is being
done
it's not an automatic process
so
so yes it is a limited number of
hearings per year
it doesn't happen
on an even spread on time and it happens
primarily in a few courts and we have
these clerks who have to make sure
everything happens on time and happens
well uh and they do it but it takes
resources and and what we've seen what
we also know in the clerics
i ramble a little bit i apologize it's a
long answer
is
when
in 2011 when we converted to a circuit
court system because remember we now
have a circuit court system made up of
three divisions the district division
the probate division
and the family division
circuit court judges hear all of those
divisions so they may have bail they may
have a domestic violence case they may
have a small claims case and they may
have all those in the same morning
because they're hearing all of the
different types of cases
when we created the circuit court in
we dramatically decreased the number of
managerial positions in the clerk's
office so we we
can get the numbers a little bit wrong
somewhere from the in the 80s into the
50s so we reduced that when we went to
electronic filing for some of the
divisions we further significantly
reduced clerk staff
in the circuit courts
thinking the electronic filing would
create the efficiencies
that would allow us to reduce staff
turns out we were wrong
and
the staff now is just overwhelmed
but
we did reduce f so so now
what we're doing this session would be
adding
um
bail reform we have two bail reform
bills that sort of collectively have a
broad impact on primarily these four
repeal of felonies first
which will shift felon initial felony
filings from the superior court into the
circuit court
so that's another load that i'm not even
talking about in the context of this
bill that's getting pushed into the
circuit court
and
in terms of the number of so i've talked
about the number of staff that's
available in the circuit court
i've also heard you know well you have
more judges now
which is true and which is fair
except we have
a reduction so not all judges are equal
so we had a number of senior judges or
per diem judges
that had retired but were still below
the age of 70 so who could perform that
number has been reduced significantly so
if i take sort of
everything and i and i count them as
what we call session days a seven and a
half hour day in which a judge can sit
and hold session we're down actually a
judge and a little over a judge
since 2015 but we have these far more
some of them incredibly complicated like
i think we've doubled the number of
uh termination of parental rights cases
and again circuit court judges hear all
of them those are remarkably complicated
and can take days in terms of of a
judge's time
so all this mix is
is important to us obviously
in terms of keeping the the trains
running on time but also making sure
that we actually get to all of the cases
and as as we
get more and more obligations that have
to be reached something slips so things
that don't have a constitutional
deadline that things that don't have a
statutory deadline
obviously get pushed because
you only have so many hours in a day
that you can do the work so i i say all
that not because i have a view on
whether it's a good or a bad bill but
it's just
it's coming to you without even a fiscal
note from us
and i do think that is relevant in terms
of your decision-making process thank
you for the question
everybody may ask and this would be a
much simpler question
so i'll try not to take 15 minutes and
answering it 2839
and the majority of those are in nashua
concord rochester in manchester
what percentage
of the 2839 cases how many of those are
in those four cities i don't know
i i did not break them down by
individual counties or
circuit courts i just have
the total numbers for those circuit
courts for all the circuit courts at
thank you mr chair
so the data that you gave us about the
2839 additional cases
is it the wording in the bill that says
the person shall be detained in
pre-trial detention is that the wording
is that what causes this additional
number of cases to have to be
heard since they now go to a judge
apparently is that is that what it is so
it could be bailed by a bail
commissioner
thank you um
and just for current right now when
people see
see bail commissioners and i believe
they won't be able to see them according
to that language
who now
um
oversees the bail commissioners and
provides for their training etc because
you said
with the hypothetical case
that they would be under the supervision
of a judge and they and and you might
get more consistency or something like
that i'm paraphrasing
so
what is the status now who oversees them
and how are they trained and and and why
are
i'm not even going to ask you why it's a
bit i'll just leave my question at that
so thank you for the question the the um
bail commissioners are not employees of
the state so they're not subject to sort
of employee type of of
oversight and personnel they are trained
through the circuit court
um and so the courts do the training are
responsible for the training and do
provide training
there are
i'll get this number wrong so don't hold
me to this number somewhere over 100
bail commissioners
so it's not a small group it's a large
group they don't have to respond
and some are some are very very good
and some are tend not to be as
responsive
and
the only remedy the court has is to
revoke a commission we don't have sort
of
your standard employee type of of
punishment that you can that you can
impose on somebody who is not performing
their duties appropriately
so we then have a process for revoking a
commission
because we don't have a process where
they would be employees subject to the
personnel rules of the judicial branch
and subject to you know what every other
employee of the judicial branch is
subject to thank you for that
thank you for that clarification
representative burke
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
do you know why the lba is not asking
for a fiscal note because to me that's a
red flag
and
as a representative sitting on this
committee
seeing this bill
uh
i i
uh thank you for the question um i don't
know
the reason why how they make a decision
on who
uh receives a a request for a fiscal
note and who doesn't it is not this
isn't the only other times that happens
sometimes you know they have a lot of
bills and and
uh they make a decision i think pretty
quickly but i don't know specifically on
on this bill as to why we would not have
seen it i have in senate bill 92
presented what would be a very similar
uh fiscal note
um for the amendment that was proposed
in in senate bill 92 it would be very
similar i've done the further analysis
that i've talked about today that's not
in that draft of
how many days of of actual hearing time
it would take but it it does outline and
it does have that breakdown
of um of cases from 2019 that i talked
about i'd be happy to obviously provide
anything to the committee that the
committee wants and i can resubmit a
copy of that it won't be updated though
if you wish
representative conley
thank you mr chairman thank you mr head
for taking the question does it stand to
reason that
uh
some of the 2849 or so folks
uh who would be now subject to this and
create that
situation in the court system
are themselves arrested multiple times
and then would be sort of taken out of
commission
uh if this bill were to pass and they
wouldn't have to i guess the point of
making is it
i think you understand the question is
it possible that one person
would be needed to be arraigned multiple
times under that number you gave um so
thank you for the question fair point um
so some of these may be the same person
we don't we don't aggregate out people
have been re-arrested so
some of these may be the same person
these are cases so so what i have are
case numbers
okay thank you and follow
up um would knowing that you know time
is somewhat of the essence and
uh
around the fiscal note and around the
logistics that you've mentioned with
delaying this to the start of the new
fiscal year address some of those
concerns allowing for time to
properly roll it out and properly fund
it
uh thank you for the question yes i
think that would absolutely you know we
could then
incorporate it into our discussion in
the budget session um would would would
be correct and then you know those those
fiscal issues could be addressed through
the budget process if the if the
effective dates took that into account
if i may inquire over a question
let's just
say for the sake we were to get a fiscal
note from the court how would it be how
would you distinguish between
expenses for court hearings that are
already scheduled to occur in factoring
the one one two or three a few extra
hearings in one day
i mean what would i would i in terms of
the fiscal note that i put together for
92 what i assumed would be a new judge
for each of those four courts and a new
clerk
staff for each of those four courts and
a court monitor
was was how i calculated the the fiscal
impact
obviously
we can we can have a conversation about
whether that is
that makes sense or not you know once
once you put it once you
[Music]
put a load on a new system
you can't you you can't re it's
difficult to respond with a
uh with a with a quarter of a judge in a
location or a quarter of a staff person
in a location so what it would
what it would so that was the reason
behind sort of the the fiscal note that
i put together for that was i'm assuming
the the
significant impact on those four courts
which are already stressed um and that
would be the the relief that would that
would be required
um it is also well i'll stop there thank
you
can you please correct me if i'm wrong
how many vacancies right now do we have
in the circuit court three uh there's
two vacancies in terms of judges um we
two judge vacancies we have a marital
master who's uh who's
indicated that he is retiring so that
would create a third vacancy
we're talking
you know
uh
in the last not today's governor council
but the last one uh one of the
circuit court judges that would be
filled was rejected nobody was
nominated today
at the governor and council so i expect
those three vacancies to continue for a
period of time
you know whatever time to get a new
judge appointed in place and trained
so it's
we're expecting a sort of a lag there
all of these have ripple effects within
the system
so you know once you take resources out
we then have to figure out what to do
with it some things get pushed further
and you know we're in we're still in
pandemic recovery
and the court systems have the same
hiring issues that other
everybody else in the state has so when
we have positions available in the
clerk's offices they're not all being
filled so we have within our full
funded clerks
staffing vacancies that we're having
difficulties
filling as as everybody's having these
days
so there's there's stress there's stress
representative true
thank you mr chair um and thank you for
taking my question
um
i i'm
massively confused on some of the
figures that were
were using here
mr head you've referred to a 3000
additional here uh
2800 3000 whatever and you factored that
to be
7.3 weeks
of new hearings per year
correct
and yet
other people are saying that these
figures only amount to 12 additional
hearings
per
so
thank you for the question um
i'll took you how i did the math
um
uh so i took the the 2800 cases
and i assumed they would all take 5.8
minutes
so that gives me i now have 16
524 minutes i have to add into the
system
that's 275 hours and if i have seven and
a half hour session days
uh that's 36 days and if i take out the
weekends i have 7.3 weeks of seven and a
half year hearing
days
of additional time i need to
representative true recognized for
follow-up thank you mr chair so
based on
senate bill 294
the new pre-trial hearings is that those
are just bail hearings
i mean bail hearings
but these these are new bail hearings
correct new no sorry yes new bail
hearings with a judge in the in in court
thank you correct
and and i caveat that with with
representative conley's point which is
some of these are probably duplicates
not duplicates but but same person twice
representative muse
thank you for taking my question again
um
with all of the attention and time that
we've been spending on trying to create
a legislative solution to the problems
that have been mentioned
i'm wondering is there are there steps
that the court system itself
is taking to address
some of the the inconsistencies some of
the anecdotes that we hear about
so thank you for the question
we do try to be responsive to when there
are complaints of of issues with with
bail commissioners we do try to provide
training
and we have and we make training
materials available at all times to bail
commissioners
when we do hear of problems where
and there certainly have been
where
inappropriate bail decisions are being
made
you know
and it's not just bail decisions that
are being made it is um our
bail commissioners informing properly
informing the defendants of their
hearing dates are they getting accurate
information from bail commissioners
are they
um
submitting paperwork to the courts on
time within the 20-day window for
arraignments
there are a large
range of potential issues that it that
that we can have with a bail
commissioner and again i want to
reiterate there are a large number of
them who are very very good
but
there are obviously times when
there's unsatisfactory performance so if
we do get a complaint those are
investigated
and
if
additional training is needed
additional training is provided if
if removal of a commission is needed
then that's then that occurs
we do try to be responsive and again
some of its staffing to make sure that
somebody's available to perform the
investigations i've seen some of those
they do occur
and
there have been
commissions that have been revoked there
have been training
opportunities given
so yes we do try to be responsive to
where we when we hear about a specific
problem
seeing no hands raising thank the
the committee now calls captain louis
and chief hobeck
mr chair members of the committee i
appreciate your patience and allowing us
to speak to you i promise to keep our
remarks brief because
i know a lot has already been said about
senate bill 294
for the record my name is joe ho becky
i'm the chief of police and halls i'm
also the current president of the new
hampshire association of chiefs of
police
and i'll let my wingman here introduce
himself
good afternoon representative abbas
respected members of the committee
i am ken louie i am a captain at the
manchester police department i am the
divisional commander of the legal and
professional standards division
so just a few quick points for the
committee um
i did want to say this
the issue of bail and um
folks being released who
necessarily shouldn't be released
is not just an issue limited to
manchester
it's actually
an issue um that
is seen throughout the state
um
you know the stories that i'm sure many
of you have heard that have been alluded
to
um
these aren't these aren't fear tactics
these are these are real stories
um
we have to answer to victims of crime we
have to answer to
members of the community that will often
contact public safety and ask why people
have been released when they maybe
shouldn't have been released
we're the ones that have to answer to
those
and that's why we're here
we're here to address a specific issue
and we have worked really hard um to try
and come up with solutions
we're willing to continue to work hard
to come up with solutions with the
various stakeholders
to make sure that you know the bail
system remains fair uh for everyone
um we feel as though the language
contained within 294 is a specific fix
it addresses
violent serious offenses which is
obviously the the first issue that many
many communities have experienced as
well as though those folks who um are
arrested released on bail and arrested
again released on bail this the cycle
that we see these are very
real issues
within the community i'll also say that
i would never
and i know i speak from my colleagues in
law enforcement we would never advocate
for a person being
denied bill
what we are saying
is that we feel as though certain
in order to make a determination on bail
those cases those instances
should be heard in front of a judge
that's what we're seeing here
and we are certainly
willing to work to come up with
uh an amended version of the bill uh to
make it more amenable to to you folks as
well as the various stakeholders
um we've considered um you know reducing
uh
the offenses within uh the first section
which carves out the specific offenses
we've also made it a point to make sure
and we will make it a point to make sure
persons not being denied bail
solely under the basis
of their financial condition remains in
the current bail statute
um
so with that uh captain do you have
anything to answer yes i would thank you
um
as a representative of the manchester
police department
you know i like to come before you and
and tell you that we do support um 294
or perhaps maybe a modified version of
that based on some of the input we've
heard today from the attorney general's
office
and others
the as well intentioned as the original
legislation back in 2018 may have been
with regard to bail reform
i think we have seen over the past year
and some months
right in the city of manchester that
this
the existing legislation just um
isn't working
um it's
uh
there's clearly there clearly uh there's
clearly room for improvement um
you know i've heard a lot about the
stories and the anecdotes and these this
is in folklore this is these are
specific cases that you can you can look
up yourself so with names and victims
you know
just in january we had uh you know a
defendant by the name of jessica
leferria she was arrested for
allegedly
physically assaulting a child this child
exhibited bruises all up and down their
body
she was released on pr bail
um
she was she was let out
where's the consideration for the victim
in this
so clearly there's
there are things that need to be
addressed and and i think that the the
language in in 294
um is a as a surgical approach it
specifically enumerates you know those
13 crimes which i think when you look at
them you can agree that those are
the most egregious crimes you know
people can commit in our society
um
so
you know we had another instance back in
september
um
very recently we had
justin shaw he he was arrested for
robbery
less than 24 hours later after being
bailed
back in
april of last year
we had a
gentleman by the name of tariq alston
who um
you know he was he was running across a
parking lot firing shots from a gun
um
he was released on pr bail and then he
was subsequently arrested several other
times subsequent to that release you
know uh for for running from the police
and falsifying physical evidence
and um
you know from for violating his bail
conditions by trying to go into a gun
store and buy ammunition
so you know there's there's clearly room
for improvement here
um i've heard a lot of
of people who are opposed to the bill
talk talk as if this is um
this is a denial of the person's right
to bail that you know this is some
attempt by law enforcement to hold
people indefinitely
um
that's it's not that at all it's it's a
it's pretty much a pumping of the brakes
i can't tell you how many times people
have been
arrested by manchester officers
to be walking out of the police station
on pr bail before the officer is even
done writing their reports
so
how can a bail commissioner make
an informed decision
if their report isn't even done yet
you know
uh you just heard from the testimony
that came before ours um you know
sometimes bail commissioners make
mistakes
and we're just trying to minimize that
because if
if 294
if the amendment is made through 294
that that pretty much puts
the full picture before a judge
during the very next arraignment date
it's not
nobody is looking to hold anybody
any longer than they need to be held but
i think it's fair to say that for these
specific 13 egregious crimes
that a judge
should take a look at the full set of
facts at the very next court date
and determine what is the appropriate
bail
and that that that
you know it's not every time you know
the bail commissioner will still serve a
function but it's for for those specific
crimes that we can all agree are are the
worst
um and the most and represent the
biggest danger to our society that that
you know perhaps somebody should take a
closer look at that
um
i'll just say this listen i i fully
understand that this is a
emotional debate
on a very important topic
and i certainly am
we certainly respect the points of view
of everyone in the testimony provided
um but we just want folks to know that
um
we have an obligation to
uh you know uphold the constitution
obviously but to protect victims and to
make sure our communities are safe and
and that is our intent in being here um
so with that we certainly appreciate
your time we'll open up to any questions
represented burt
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
the scenarios you gave
the committee you know with the crimes
uh one gentleman running through a
if i understood the previous testimony
those people can be held
at those crime levels
yes
yes sir they can be
the the
there have been instances however
when the bail commissioner releases an
individual
and that person is cut loose on pr
that person's already out even if we
subsequently engage in the mechanisms
that allow us to challenge
that later on that person is still now
free
after allegedly committing some very
serious crimes
so it's it's
yes to answer your question there is a
way to prevent that from happening
but it's not it's not as easy as you
know bail commissioner goes i i'm going
to release it on pr and the officer says
i don't think that's a good idea and
then it stops it's no
you have to file a motion and it has to
be heard in a court next day
um
so it's
kind of but you know that's not how i'm
understanding that you know i'm hearing
that if the police
do the paperwork right
and not saying that you don't but if
there's a certain way to do it to lock
these people up to make sure they have
to go in front of a judge because
somebody running through the parking lot
shooting a gun in the air
he shouldn't be out and i understand
that they can lock him up in the the
bail guy
you know cannot release him
and that's
that's our point with those specifically
carved out
uh offenses listed in the very beginning
section of
this piece of legislation is
that should be a determination in our
opinion made by a judge not a bail
commissioner so those errors don't occur
and i think that's what we we find there
are issues here i mean these folks there
are instances these are not
um you know fictional stories
people are being released and they
shouldn't be released we need to fix it
all right thank you thank you for your
question sorry
and i know there have been a lot of um
facts and figures thrown around um
by some people who oppose the
legislation and um
you know we we at the manchester police
department conducted our own assessment
um
12 months
we looked at the 12 months prior to the
2018 legislation and then the 12 months
subsequent
to that legislation being enacted
and what we found is that even though
subsequent to the bail reform
legislation being enacted we saw a
decrease a five percent decrease in
arrests
we saw a 20 increase
uh in arrests by offenders who were
already out on bail
so
that's that's a local figure that's a
representative schultz
thank you mr chair
um and thank you for taking my question
um it might take me a minute to figure
out how to ask this but
um
it's helpful to hear these cases
i'm a rep from concord and i have talked
to at least the former police chief and
current officers about this
and um obviously
if it can be improved the existing law
it should be but i have two very
different
questions the first is following up on
what the representative from goffstown
asked
if
what you're saying
is what the law
says we shouldn't be doing
on the cases that you mentioned you know
and i get it on a case-by-case basis
uh it differs but
um
then wouldn't the problem actually be
with the bail commissioners themselves
not the existing law
and then i have a follow-up that's a
different
topic
thank you
well again based on the previous
testimony we heard that you know the
bail commissioners are human beings
they're they're not infallible so errors
are made
and sometimes errors are made to the
detriment of public safety
and i mean we're
we're not saying that in every crime
bail commissioners should be taken out
of it it's it's very the the the
proposed legislation in 294 the proposed
language is very specific for these
types of crimes the worst of the worst
that's when we want to take the bail
commissioner out of the mix and bring
the defendant before a judge when the
judge has the full report the full facts
being presented by the state
to to take into consideration before
they make that determination
so that's
does that answer your question it does
to a degree i think there's just a piece
of this that
in my opinion needs more exploration but
that's helpful
to the separate issue
as i asked it of others who testified
today
lines one through three
that's the uh no more than 72 hours at
the time of their his or her arrest
excluding saturday sundays and holidays
the discussion around that piece has
centered around with previous folks
testifying
around this the scenarios that um
on that and a subsequent portion
that the intervening circumstances that
a person might be encountering separate
from the anyone that i think we would
all agree
violent criminals
or
uh alleged criminals
uh
probably shouldn't be released i mean i
don't understand why that's happening
but
but for those that are not committing
violent offenses
are problematic especially when
our social safety net
is broken and i
i apologize i i get that i'm sort of
testifying i don't mean to do that um
but i'm thinking of my conversation with
concord police
the one thing i know
i think we can all agree on is that law
enforcement addressing social problems
like
people who don't have a home
or place to stay
child care employment
i know there's a question coming yes the
is
wouldn't you say
looking to our police officers to solve
those issues
uh you know including addiction
um
wouldn't you say
there are other
ways for society to address that
than through law enforcement and that
something that we continue to keep at
the forefront of this conversation
of why
perhaps
bail reform has been needed all along
i forgive
when you got to the question
when you got to the question there was
about four questions in there i
apologize
we sometimes refer that as a compound
question
so i think you know what i'm getting at
but mr chair you've been amazing the
good news is being here as a substitute
he's letting me speak it's amazing the
good news is there's two witnesses to
attempt to answer
whatever that was and then let me get my
20-point
uh powerpoint
i think you know what i'm asking
if i may mr chair answer the question
do your best i think the best word i can
probably answer uh
your question with is balance right
there's balance and everything and we
certainly want to balance the needs of
public safety but knowing full well
that there are folks that need help that
we can't provide to them just because
it's beyond our means
and so um i'm not sure how that relates
i i
you know to bail in in this specific
amendment but i certainly think you know
it's a relevant point and it's one that
we need to consider i mean the previous
folks that have spoken about
uh this issue have spoken about you know
society's approach to crime
and it's a deeper issue that i can't
answer here and we can't answer here in
five or ten minutes so
point well taking them thank you very
much and again i
the chair has been amazing and generous
thank you
representative calmly
thank you mr chairman thank you uh to
you both for your testimony and not to
jump on my colleague from concord but
i'm not aware of anyone who's been
charged
with a uh charged with being addicted to
drugs or charged with being homeless
those aren't crimes that i'm aware of so
people who are arrested are accused of
crimes or are they not
and
okay thank you i just want to clarify
thank you for thank you mr chair and
thank you for taking my question um i
asked this of an earlier
um an earlier
person was satisfying but so what
happens to folks who you know
i understand you all have a really
difficult job
making sure you keep the public safe but
what happens when
someone is is arrested and they're
uh
they're and they're held and then
they're proven that they're actually
innocent is there any compensation or
what happens to that person because you
know obviously being being held is a
very traumatic you know incident for
them especially if they're held
innocently
sure i i think you asked that to the
representative from the aclu and i think
those are handled
maybe someone else i'm not sure but um
obviously those are handled on a case by
case basis really what we're here to
talk about is bail um we're
you know with bail we're not presuming
anyone's guilty of a crime we're
we're just saying that in circum certain
circumstances
that there are
instances where we feel it's appropriate
that those specific cases be heard
before a judge to make a determination
on bail not guilt or innocence
thank you mr chair
i'm going to go back to the the list of
crimes in line 26 through line 3 on page
2.
and it says upon arrest shall be
be detained for a period of not more
than 72 hours from the time of his or
her arrest excluding saudi sunday's
holidays except
also
based upon the
rebuttable presumption of a person
charged
and i agree i i agree with that for the
major crimes that you all said that have
been carefully carved out
but then as we go down in the paragraph
and we go down to line 25
and it says
and the person shall be detained in
pre-trial detention
to me that eliminates the bio the bail
commissioners who are part of the court
as
amended on page one it says it says the
court shall be judges in in
bail commissioners
so this bill the way it's worded right
now
says there is a rebuttable
presumption
and then it says but they shall be
detained
and that means that the person does not
get a chance to rebut that
and unless he sees a judge
he just cannot see the judge
it has to go to a judge
so that's why i have a problem where
there is a presumption that they're
guilty
even they've only been charged with a
crime
and then when the shell comes in it says
you you don't have that anymore which
i think exactly right maybe you're
confused about that
am i obviously confused about that
if i may real quick i i think there is a
solution to that if uh
if we may
and possibly through an amended version
of
of the bill if we can work on that part
i i don't necessarily think that's
um
the case in the circumstance i think the
rebuttable presumption would would
assume that the person be held until
well let me
we'll we'll get there uh represent
bournemouth and then okay
thank you mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question
um
so
presumption seems to be in this bill
that
bill commissioners are making mistakes
in their detention hearings
um
do judges make the mistakes in their
well again sir um respectfully
the
judges are human beings
but the um what this
what this proposed language in the bill
is trying to address is um
you know sometimes
the bail commissioner is making a
decision with less than all of the
information whereas a judge
with their high degree of legal training
and now they have a full set of facts
before them with all the reports
completed
and having a prosecutor be able to argue
the points in those reports and in the
affidavit that a
you're improving the likelihood that
you're going to get a more appropriate
bail i mean no cis there's no guarantee
to anything right i mean human you know
judges are human so yeah could a judge
make a bad decision absolutely i mean
any of us could right um but it just it
gives the entire system
more time
to um
take full account of what has transpired
in these 13 enumerated
worst of the worst crimes
does that answer your question sir
uh thank you it does partially
um
but already the the law
allows us to retain people that are
a danger to themselves or the general
public without mentioning what crimes
that they are
being charged with and if i
i don't see
in on this list terrorism as a
possible crime for
retention
and so that means that even that is a
serious crime and a
danger to the public then
they should get a hearing before a bail
commissioner
i i guess i'm not going to disagree with
perhaps this list of crimes is is
is is really something that we shouldn't
be doing we should be just looking and
using our judgment to determine what is
a serious crime and what is serious
uh
concern for for person safety are the
i i would submit respectfully sir that
that's what we're all attempting to do
collectively here is determine what is
serious and what should
um go before a judge rather than a bail
commissioner
that's i think we're all trying to do
that
at with
294. uh thank you
representative bourne if i can is there
a rsa that defines or
the crime of terrorism
that anyone's aware of uh mr chairman i
don't think that we have a a uh
rsa that they uh describes terrorism but
uh you would admit that if someone was
to commit a cri a
event of terrorism that it would be uh
serious
i would most certainly agree with that
and i would be shocked if someone did
not agree with that
almost chairman do we need to have an
rsa to define terrorism i'm willing to
work on that with you thank you
all right mr chair i just want to take a
point of personal privilege right well
okay i gotta hey we're gonna let
well this is a quick question um you
i believe it was
um i forget your name but from
manchester you mentioned that
the person had
was bailed out before your officer
completed his um his report
correct
yes that does happen ma'am so
how does the how did the bill's been
i think i'm missing a process or maybe
the process is off
that that could happen
typically when the reports are not done
the bail commissioner will speak with
the arresting officer and the arresting
officer will to the best of their
ability to come convey all the facts of
the case so that they can make a
decision so the report may not be
completed but there is a verbal exchange
so they do have some information
um
the problem is obviously that's not
that's an imperfect process right that's
going to be that's going to be less
comprehensive than a fully written
report or affidavit
so you know sometimes it's just a verbal
exchange you know lasting maybe 10
minutes
so um
what if
i guess if um
have you ever had the cases yourself
where you felt that the commissioner did
not do his job correctly
and so did you follow through with the
prosecutor or with the courts or
whatever you said would happen the very
next day
i think you mentioned
ma'am not myself personally no um i i
haven't been in the patrol division for
for quite some time so i haven't
personally experienced that but i have i
have read the reports in which
those types of incidents had occurred
those instances have occurred okay so
then they did file an appeal or
something the next day or whenever that
takes do you know what any of the um
results were
i i don't know i don't have any
specifics i'm sorry yeah
well
i think that's very important
information that i think we would need
to know um because if you if you're
saying that these people are releasing
people and they shouldn't be
okay and the law says that they
shouldn't be released based on the
reading
then i would seriously would like to
know how often this happens that they're
released like that and when you file the
report i mean when you filed you know
with the courts
what they're what were the outcomes of
it you know did they agree with you did
something happen with the commissioner
you know
i just feel as though
we're hearing a lot about those types of
things just want to have some type of
data
yes ma'am and i'm not
i can't tell you for a fact that that
date is definitely there but we can
certainly make an attempt to look at
that
didn't i ask a question
i apologize
okay oh so you made me forget what my
i have to think now what's up my next
question
when any of the members are saying are
offensive we just was
supposed to ask a question of the
witness we can when we talk amongst
ourselves in the work session or
executive says different but
it's uh
going forward and do a better job as a
chair to try to be stricter with that
do you have a
not right now
all right
see no hands right i want to thank the
witnesses for the testimony and for
taking our questions thank you for your
time
representative paraguay you wish to ask
a question of the previous witness you
may
the committee now calls kate horgan
okay
are there any members of the public who
wish to testify
seeing no hands raised
and
you wish to
address
we're not going to execute this bill
mr
mr chair i just wanted to make the point
since um
my points
were challenged in a question to the
previous folks testifying
as a concord rep
it is clear to me
that
the state hospital
the men's prison the women's prison all
discharging folks
in concord
there certainly are a number of issues
that concord faces that maybe every
other town and city of new hampshire
doesn't understand
but i'll also say it's rather unique
when the points i raised get the
agreement of the aclu
and americans for prosperity
thank you that's it point of personal
privilege that's not about me
those they those organizations agree on
so
the the side-by-side worksheet and i
this is going to be this bill will be
scheduled for a work session on next
wednesday
that's right
so i would just go through
that worksheet and kind of see the
differences between what we passed in
this committee as an amendment to what
the we have now with senate bill 294.
and
it wasn't my opinion a significant
difference especially with the first
section involving the list of crimes
and then if there's any issues with the
list of crimes that are on there whether
something should be added
or removed
but at this time i think we you know
well now uh the committee will
well
so close yes if i may i did find on my
table here uh senate bill 401
and health and human services is that
something we're looking at
i think that was a mistake that's not
today
oh it's a friday okay thank you
make sure you read it before friday's
hearing okay
represent newman last question we can
recess yeah i just have a question to
help with scheduling purposes
do you anticipate a lot of wednesday
friday
us being here or
any days that we should be looking at
that we should probably be here
or anything you want to offer now since
uh
since we've been meeting in person the
i've been recommending we reserve
wednesdays and fridays
um
you